Herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR.
Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und ich begrüße alle zur 38.
Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsserie.
Heute hat mich der Weg nach Aachen geführt und ganz anders als das hier in allen anderen,
oder zumindest in den meisten anderen Sendungen der Fall ist,
befinde ich mich diesmal weder an einem Standort der ESA noch des DLR,
sondern der Weg hat mich geführt zum RWTH,
der Universität in Aachen und dort ganz konkret zum Lehrstuhl der Physik.
War das die richtige Bezeichnung? Ich werde es gleich erfahren,
denn mein Gesprächspartner ist Dr.
Stefan Scheel. Schönen guten Tag, hallo, willkommen zu Raumzeit.
Hallo.
Wie ist denn die korrekte Bezeichnung? Ich habe ganz vergessen nachzuschlagen.
Also korrekte Bezeichnung ist, Sie sind im ersten physikalischen Institut der RWTH Aachen gelandet.
Wie gibt es denn noch?
Lehrstuhl für Experimentalphysik. Es gibt drei Institute für Experimentalphysik an der RWTH Aachen.
Es ist einer der größten Standorte in Deutschland, an der Physikforschung gemacht
wird und natürlich auch Ausbildung.
Wir haben etwa 1000 Physikstudenten an der RWTH Aachen, die wir ausbilden.
Und neben den experimentellen Instituten gibt es natürlich auch noch Lehrstühle
für Theoretische Physik.
Und dann rüber hinaus haben wir noch eine enge Zusammenarbeit in der Physik
mit dem Forschungszentrum Jülich.
Also es gibt vielfältige Möglichkeiten hier in der Physik zu studieren und zu forschen.
Das heißt Physik hat auch generell für die Universität eine große Bedeutung.
Das hat die Physik sicherlich. Zum einen ist es natürlich so,
dass wir in Aachen insbesondere in den Ingenieurwissenschaften eine der führenden
Universitäten in Europa sind und weltweit.
Und die Physikausbildung ist natürlich ein zentraler Punkt in der Ingenieurausbildung.
Darüber hinaus hat sich die RWTH Aachen im Rahmen der Exzellenzinitiative der
Bundesregierung vorgenommen, insbesondere auf dem Gebiet der Naturwissenschaften
an die führenden Universitäten Anschluss zu finden.
Denn wir haben gesehen, dass wenn man also Universitäten wie ETH Zürich oder
MIT mit Aachen vergleicht, dass dann im Wesentlichen der Unterschied ist,
dass wir in den Naturwissenschaften nicht konkurrenzfähig sind.
Und zwar nicht, weil wir nicht gut genug sind, sondern weil wir nicht groß genug sind.
Das heißt, es ist eine Frage, wie man Ressourcen verteilt und wir haben die
Mittel aus der Exzellenzinitiative massiv genutzt, um die Naturwissenschaften
auszubauen und haben das auch für die nächste Runde der Exzellenzinitiative so vorgeschlagen.
Das ist allerdings noch nicht entschieden. Die Entscheidung fällt am 15. Juni.
Dann werden wir sehen, ob RWTH Aachen weiter zu den neuen exzellenten Universitäten
in Deutschland gehört, wie bisher auch.
Ja, jetzt ist gerade der Mai 2012.
Vielleicht auch mal ganz wertvoll hier zu sagen, wann wir die Aufnahme denn
machen. Auf der Webseite vermerken wir es ohnehin immer wieder.
Ja, warum bin ich jetzt hierher gekommen? Letzten Endes dreht es sich ja bei
Raumzeit vor allem um ein Format, was sich der Raumfahrt widmet.
Hier an diesem Institut wurde ein ganz konkretes Experiment entwickelt und was
jetzt bereits im Einsatz ist und zum Einsatz gekommen ist auf der ISS,
allerdings ist die Geschichte ja auch noch ein bisschen länger.
Konkret möchten wir hier reden über das Alpha-Magnet-Spektrometer und die damit
verbundene wissenschaftlichen Fragestellungen.
Was sind denn diese wissenschaftlichen Fragestellungen, die einen in diesen
Bereich hineintreiben?
Also die Physik gegenwärtig, wenn man sich das nicht jetzt von der Anwendungsseite
anguckt, sondern von der Grundlagenforschung anguckt,
Hat einige Schwierigkeiten, was vielleicht viele zu überraschen wird,
denn wir benutzen die Physik ja auch im Alltag.
Aber von der Grundlagenforschung her haben wir eigentlich seit etwa 100 Jahren
das Dilemma, dass die Überlegungen, die Heisenberg,
Dirac, Pauli angestellt haben zur Quantenmechanik, sich nicht vertragen mit den Überlegungen,
die Albert Einstein zur allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie, zur Wechselwirkung
der Gravitation angestellt haben.
Das heißt konkret, es gibt Bereiche im Universum, wo unsere Physik nicht funktioniert.
Also wo unser bisheriges Modell von wie alles zusammenhängt nicht funktioniert.
Richtig, also wir müssen ja unterscheiden zwischen Realität und dem,
was wir im Modell beschreiben.
Also die Physik erhebt nicht den Anspruch, dass sie die Realität beschreibt,
sondern nur, dass wir ein Modell liefern, was es uns erlaubt in vielen Fällen Vorhersagen zu machen.
Denn das ist ja eigentlich die Aufgabe der Physik. Sie wollen Physik benutzen,
um bestimmte Prozesse zu verstehen und dann Vorhersagen zu können.
Also bei einem Verbrennungsmotor, ich muss den Brennraum so und so auslegen,
weil die thermodynamischen Prozesse, die da ablaufen, auf der und der Basis
funktionieren, um ein Beispiel zu sagen.
Und die Physik hat eigentlich den Anspruch, dass sie sämtliche Phänomene in
der Natur beschreiben kann.
Und wir haben wiederholt gemerkt, dass wir dazu nicht in der Lage sind.
Jetzt werden viele sagen, wenn das in einigen Situationen nicht funktioniert,
warum beunruhigt euch das so?
Und das kann man am besten verstehen, wenn man sich da eine Analogie anguckt.
Vor etwas mehr als 100 Jahren hat Max Planck sich gefragt, ob er Physik studieren soll.
Und ist an die Uni gegangen, hat mit einem Physikprofessor geredet.
Und der Physikprofessor hat gesagt, das lohnt sich eigentlich nicht.
Die Physik ist abgeschlossen. Es gibt noch ein paar kleine Bereiche,
wo wir das nicht verstehen, aber die sind so peripher, das lohnt sich eigentlich nicht.
Vor 100 Jahren.
Vor etwas über 100 Jahren.
Ja.
Max Planck hat dann natürlich doch Physik studiert, wie wir heute wissen.
Und er hat sich mit einem Bereich in der Physik beschäftigt,
der völlig an der Peripherie liegt und wo überhaupt nicht klar ist,
dass die Beschäftigung damit wirklich den Durchbruch in der Physik bringt.
Er hat sich mit der Wärmestrahlung eines schwarzen Körpers beschäftigt.
Und die Modelle, die man damals hatte, haben das nicht vernünftig beschreiben können.
Und Planck hat erkannt, dass die einzige Möglichkeit, das zu beschreiben,
ist, dass er also das, was wir heute Planck'sches Wirkungsquantum einführen,
dass er also die Energie quantisiert, wie wir sagen, und damit die Grundlagen
für die Quantenmechanik gelegt hat.
Und wenn Sie sich heute unsere Welt angucken, also auf dieser Erkenntnis beruht
unser Verständnis, wie Solarzellen funktionieren, wie ein Transistor funktioniert,
Wie ein Computer funktioniert.
Das heißt, wenn Sie sich angucken, was sind heute die börsennotierten Unternehmen mit dem höchsten Wert?
Apple, Google, Facebook, Amazon.
Ebay.
Das heißt, 100 Jahre später, unser gesamter Wohlstand beruht auf diesen Arbeiten
in der Grundlagenforschung.
Und das heißt, für die Physik war es und ist es ein erfolgreiches Modell,
versuchen zu verstehen, Beispiele zu finden, wo die physikalischen Theorien,
die wir heute haben, nicht funktionieren.
Also Popper hat uns gelehrt, wir können nie eine physikalische Theorie beweisen,
wir können sie immer nur widerlegen.
Das heißt also, um das einfach zu sagen, die Beobachtung von noch so vielen
weißen Schwänen berechtigt nicht zu der Aussage, dass alle Schwäne weiß sind.
Die Physik versucht unendlich viele Phänomene zu beschreiben Also wir sagen
nicht, das gilt nur für die fünf Atome die wir uns angucken,
sondern wir sagen, das gilt für alle Atome im Universum Das heißt,
wir können nie beweisen, dass das richtig ist,
Aber wenn wir ein einziges Atom finden, für das das nicht funktioniert wie wir
das vorhersagen, dann wissen wir, dass unsere Theorie nicht in Ordnung ist und
dann ist das normalerweise ein Hinweis darauf dass es einen Themenkomplex gibt,
mit dem wir uns besser auseinandersetzen wenn wir Fortschritt haben wollen.
Ist das nicht hochgradig frustrierend, wenn man weiß, dass man eigentlich nie
irgendwas beweisen kann?
Das ist immer die Frage, welchen Anspruch man hat. Also ich bin sehr damit zufrieden,
dass wir Modelle entwickeln, die, es ist schwierig zu sagen,
welchen Bruchteil des Universums, aber wenn Sie sich unsere Zivilisation angucken,
unseren Wohlstand angucken, dann stellen Sie fest,
dass wir das recht erfolgreich machen seit einigen hundert Jahren.
Also seitdem wir ernsthaft seit Galileo Newton angefangen haben,
Wissenschaft zu machen, dass wir das recht erfolgreich machen.
Also die ganzen Sachen, an die sie heute gewöhnt sind, ob das Laser oder Navigationssystem
ist, können nehmen, was sie wollen.
Können sie ohne die moderne Physik, haben sie keine Chance.
Und wenn wir uns heute angucken, was sind die globalen Herausforderungen,
mit denen wir zu tun haben, also ob das Erderwärmung ist, alternde Gesellschaft, was auch immer. Also.
Ist eigentlich die Erkenntnis, wir werden das wahrscheinlich,
diese Probleme nicht dadurch lösen, dass wir das bestehende Know-how,
ich sage jetzt mal ein bisschen despektierlich, aber einfach nur ingenieren.
Also um wieder ein Beispiel zu sagen, Sie können sich noch so lange damit auseinandersetzen,
wie Sie eine Kerze optimieren.
Sobald ein Physiker kommt und Ihnen erklärt, wie eine Glühbirne funktioniert,
haben Sie keine Chance mehr.
Und sie können noch so lange versuchen als Ingenieur die Glühbirne zu optimieren,
sobald ein Physiker kommt und ihnen sagt, was eine LED ist, also wie sie Licht
erzeugen können ohne Wärme über quantenmechanische Prozesse,
haben sie mit ihrer Glühbirne keine Chance mehr.
Und man sieht an diesen Sprüngen in der Qualität, dass das was ganz anderes
ist, als wenn ich also einen bestehenden Prozess nehme und den Prozess immer weiter optimiere.
Irgendwann in diesem Prozess hoffentlich kommt die Physik wieder.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen, also warum mache ich Physik?
Ja, weil mich diese Themen interessieren, kommt die Physik wieder mit einer
grundlegenden neuen Idee und das revolutioniert das gesamte Gebiet.
Das ist mein Verständnis von Grundlagenforschung und warum man Grundlagenforschung machen muss.
Wir werden die Probleme, die wir heute haben, nicht dadurch lösen,
dass wir also Engineering machen von den bekannten Lösungen,
sondern wir brauchen grundsätzlich neue Ansätze.
Und dann ist die Frage, wo bekomme ich die her?
Im Nachhinein ist das einfach zu sagen, Planck mit seinem Wirkungsquantum,
das war ja die richtige Idee.
Die ganzen anderen tausend Physiker, die zu der Zeit an verschiedenen Fragen
gearbeitet haben, über die reden wir heute nicht mehr.
Und genau so ist das heute. Wir arbeiten an Grundlagenforschung,
wir versuchen Themenkomplexe zu verstehen, die uns aufzeigen,
dass unsere Physik unvollständig ist.
Welche von diesen Ansätzen am Ende zum Erfolg führen und zu dem Durchbruch führen,
das werden wir in 100 Jahren diskutieren.
Also wir nicht, also unsere Nachfolger werden dann bei solch einem Interview
sitzen und dann werden sie sagen, ja, damals AMS, das war das Schlüsselexperiment, vielleicht.
Wie wir heute sagen, Michelson-Morley, Messung der Konstanz der Lichtgeschwindigkeit
vor 100 Jahren, das war das entscheidende Experiment, um die Relativitätstheorie zu begründen.
Oder die Messung der Wärmestrahlung eines schwarzen Körpers,
das war das entscheidende Experiment, um die Quantenmechanik zu begründen.
Was für sich genommen erstmal total banal und gegebenenfalls vollständig unwichtig klingt.
Was für den, selbst für den Experten auf dem Gebiet schwer einzuschätzen ist,
was die Bedeutung solch einer Messung ist.
Weil es dann noch zusätzlich halt solcher Köpfe wie Heisenberg oder Einstein
bedarf, um aus diesen Messungen, diesen Erkenntnissen dann die passende Theorie zu machen.
Wobei man auch sagen muss, die experimentellen Ergebnisse, die haben sich eigentlich nie geändert.
Also die werden präziser, die decken andere Bereiche ab. Das,
was sich ändert, sind unsere Theorien.
Das heißt, dass unsere Modelle, wie wir diese experimentellen Daten zusammennehmen
und damit Vorhersagen machen, die sind variabel.
Und vielleicht versteht man dann, warum ich also sage, dass Experimentalphysik
das Spannende ist, weil wir liefern die Grundlagen dafür, die sozusagen,
wenn wir es richtig gemacht haben, in Stein gemeißelt sind und die Theoretiker
dazu zwingen, ihre Modelle so anzupassen, dass sie diese Daten beschreiben können.
Und dann mit diesen Modellen Vorhersagen zu machen in Bereichen,
in denen wir nicht gemessen haben, die dann für die Anwendung relevant sind oder sein können.
Da stellt sich natürlich jetzt vor allem die Frage, was sind denn jetzt die
paar Experimente und paar Betrachtungsorte, die noch Fragen aufwerfen,
beziehungsweise die vielleicht auch noch gar nicht durchgeführt worden sind.
Wenn man sich heute den Stand der Physik anschaut und wie auch eigentlich wie
vor 100 Jahren das Gefühl hat, naja, vielleicht sollte ich doch was anderes
studieren, ist ja eigentlich nichts mehr zu erfinden.
Was antwortet denn da der Mensch mit Einblick?
Was sind denn so gerade die großen Fragestellungen, die Lücken,
die gefüllt werden müssen?
Heute würde die Antwort wahrscheinlich anders aussehen. Also zum einen mit der
Erfahrung aus der Vergangenheit, aber man muss auch sehen, dass sich in den
letzten zehn Jahren eigentlich eine Revolution weitgehend unbemerkt von der
Öffentlichkeit in der Physik abgespielt hat.
Unser Verständnis dessen, wie unser Universum entstanden ist,
hat sich grundlegend geändert in den letzten zehn Jahren.
Und zwar im Wesentlichen durch Messungen von Satellitenexperimenten,
also Weltraum-Experimenten, nicht durch Beobachtungen hier auf der Erde.
Die Messungen der kosmischen Hintergrundstrahlung durch das COBE-Experiment,
durch das WMAP-Experiment und jetzt durch das Planck-Experiment,
das Hubble Space Telescope, die entdeckt haben, dass also nicht nur das Universum
nicht schrumpft, wie man das eigentlich auf der Basis der Urknalltheorie erwarten
würde, sondern dass es anfängt, sich beschleunigt, wieder auszudehnen.
Die Erkenntnis, dass ein wesentlicher Teil des Universums aus einer Energieform
besteht, die wir nicht beschreiben können, mit der gegenwärtigen Physik,
was also die dunkle Energie ist.
Die Erkenntnis, dass der größte Teil der Materie im Universum dunkle Materie
ist, die wir mit der heutigen Physik nicht beschreiben können,
von der wir nicht wissen, was es ist.
Eigentlich ist die ernüchternde Erkenntnis der letzten zehn Jahre von vier Prozent
dessen, was das Universum ist, wissen wir halbwegs, wie es funktioniert.
Und das ist die normale Materie, aus der wir aufgebaut sind.
Das ist das, was die Physik heute kann.
96 Prozent verstehen wir nicht. Und wir sind eigentlich jetzt in der Lage oder
haben das Gefühl, in der Lage zu sein, die richtigen Fragen zu stellen.
Wir haben nicht die Antworten, aber wir sind in der Lage, die richtigen Fragen zu stellen.
Und die Aufgabe für die nächsten 10 Jahre, 15 Jahre wird es sein,
zu versuchen, auf diese Fragen eine Antwort zu finden.
Und diese Fragen sind sehr komplex, sehr schwierig, haben wenig mit unserer
Alltagsanschauung zu tun.
Es ist mehr und mehr so, dass die Grundlagenforschung in der Physik sich von den...
Ja, von den Alltagserfahrungen mehr und mehr löst. Also wenn wir in den ganz
kleinen Längenskalen gehen zur Quantenmechanik oder zu ganz großen Längenskalen
zur Astrophysik und Kosmologie,
dass das nichts mit dem zu tun hat, was wir über die Evolution eigentlich gelernt
haben, um überleben zu können.
Und das macht das sehr schwierig für uns Menschen mit unserem begrenzten Verstand,
diese Phänomene überhaupt zu durchdringen.
Und ich gehe davon aus, dass wir dafür, genauso wie Einstein eine neue Mathematik
brauchte, um seine Relativitätstheorie aufzustellen, dass wir auch neue mathematische
Verfahren brauchen werden, um diese Probleme zu lösen.
Das heißt, es lohnt sich sogar noch, Mathematik zu studieren,
weil sogar da wäre noch was zu holen.
Genauso wie Riemann zum Glück Mathematik studiert hat und damit die Grundlagen
für Einsteins Relativitätstheorie mathematisch gelegt haben,
bin ich der Meinung, dass, also ja, selbstverständlich, Mathematik sollte man
studieren, Physik sollte man studieren.
In der Physik ist es so, dass es eigentlich extrem spannend ist zurzeit und
für die nächsten Jahre sein wird, auf diese Fragestellungen eine Antwort zu kriegen.
Und wenn ich mir mal überlege, ich weiß nur von 4% des Universums,
was es ist, von 96% habe ich keine Idee, dann habe ich nicht das Problem,
dass ich mich mit kleinen Problemen beschäftige.
Das hört sich nach einem großen Problem an. Und wenn wir das verstanden haben,
ist dann die Frage, mit den Hilfsmitteln, die wir entwickeln müssen,
um das zu verstehen und mit den Erkenntnissen, die wir gewinnen,
wenn wir das verstanden haben, welche Auswirkungen wird das in anderen Bereichen haben?
Ich würde da ganz gerne mal konkret drauf eingehen, weil ich denke,
dass es auch nicht unbedingt so vielen Leuten so klar geworden ist,
wie grundlegend die Veränderungen der letzten zehn Jahre waren.
Es sind ja schon ein paar Experimente genannt worden,
also vor allem natürlich die Weltraumteleskope, die Systeme,
die halt weit ins All und damit auch in die Zeit hineinschauen,
haben viele Ergebnisse geliefert, die überrascht haben.
Ich meine, die Entdeckung der Hintergrundstrahlung ist ja schon ein bisschen
länger her, aber gerade dieses Experiment,
ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau von wem das war, der festgestellt hat,
dass das Weltall sich weiter ausdehnt und die Geschwindigkeit noch weiter zunimmt.
Was fühlt man denn da so als Physiker, wenn man dann morgens aufwacht,
Zeitung aufschlägt und man sagt, liest die Nachricht, alles ist anders?
Also erstmal ist es so, dass wir…,
immer wieder Beobachtungsdaten haben, die wir nicht verstehen.
Also eine der Erkenntnisse zum Beispiel, dass es so etwas wie dunkle Materie geben muss,
wenn man die Ergebnisse nur richtig interpretiert hätte, hätte man da schon
in den 1930er Jahren drauf kommen können, als Zwicky sich die Bewegung von größeren
Strukturen im Kosmos angeguckt hat und festgestellt hat,
dass man das aufgrund des Gravitationsgesetzes nur verstehen kann,
wenn es eine zusätzliche Materieform gibt.
Wenn Sie solche Beobachtungen isoliert haben, dann ist immer die Frage,
es stimmt was mit der Beobachtung nicht, stimmt was mit dem Modell nicht.
Die Frage ist, wie gut ist unser Verständnis der Gravitationswechselwirkung
bei den Skalen, auf denen wir arbeiten, denn wir testen das ja immer nur auf der Erde.
Dann können wir das im Sonnensystem testen mit einiger Präzision.
Jetzt gehen sie damit hin und beschreiben Galaxienhaufen oder Rotationskurven von Galaxien.
Das heißt, wie schnell dreht sich ein Stern um das Zentrum dieser Galaxie,
verstehe ich, dass der nicht aus der Galaxie rausfliegt, aufgrund der Materieverteilung.
Und dann stellt sich halt bei einigen dieser Beobachtungen raus,
das sind keine Beobachtungsfehler oder Fehler in der Theorie,
sondern da steckt wirklich was hinter.
Und wir haben durch die Beobachtung der kosmischen Hintergrundstrahlung,
was wir uns eigentlich angeguckt haben, ist, hat das Universum die gleiche Temperatur,
egal in welche Richtung ich gucke?
Was ja eigentlich eine interessante Frage ist. Also wenn das Universum ohne
Vorzugsrichtung erzeugt worden ist, würde man ja sagen, ja, das müsste eigentlich
überall ungefähr gleich aussehen.
Dann stellt sich natürlich die spannende Frage, wenn das gleich aussieht,
wie können Bereiche, die also keinen kausalen Zusammenhang haben,
das heißt, die so weit voneinander entfernt sind, dass sie über Lichtgeschwindigkeit
keine Informationen austauschen können, wie können die eine gleiche Temperatur haben?
Und das ist normalerweise eine Frage, da finden Sie keine Antwort drauf.
Die Idee, die dann vor 20 Jahren aufkam, 30 Jahren aufkam, war,
dass es also eine Inflationsphase am Anfang gab.
Das heißt, das Universum hat sich also exponentiell ausgedehnt aus einem sehr
kleinen Raumzeitgebiet. In
dem kleinen Raumzeitgebiet können Sie dann homogene Bedingungen schaffen.
Das ist klein genug, dass Sie über Lichtgeschwindigkeit Informationen austauschen
können. Dann blähen Sie das exponentiell auf. Wir verstehen heute nicht, warum.
Das nimmt eine bestimmte Größe an. Dieser exponentielle Wachstum hört auf.
Auch da wissen wir nicht, warum es aufhört. Dann dehnt es sich langsam weiter
aus, beziehungsweise Gravitationskraft gewinnt die Überhand und dann sollte
es sich wieder zusammenziehen, je nachdem, wie viel Materie in dem Universum
ist. Die Anfangsbedingungen kennen wir ja nicht genau.
Und dieses Modell, was wir heute haben, das sieht recht plausibel aus.
Und wenn Sie das in der Relativitätstheorie angucken, dann hat Einstein eigentlich
alle Zutaten schon geliefert.
Er hat das kosmologische Konstante genannt, also diese Vakuumenergie,
die notwendig ist, um solche Expansionen vorher zu verursachen.
Und Einstein hat damals gesagt, diese Einführung dieser kosmologischen Konstante
in meine Relativitätstheorie, das war der größte Unfug, den ich gemacht habe,
als Hubble entdeckt hat, dass das Universum sich tatsächlich ausdehnt,
also dass unsere Nachbargalaxien von uns wegfliegen.
Und Einstein hat dann gedacht, naja, das ist also ein mathematisches Kuriosum,
dass ich da eine Konstante habe, die hat keine Bedeutung.
Und dann kam die Messung von dem Hubble-Weltraumteleskop, das also festgestellt
hat, dass das Universum sich beschleunigt, ausdehnt.
Dann kam die Messung der kosmischen Hintergrundstrahlung, was auch festgestellt
hat, dass wir die Messergebnisse nur verstehen können, wenn wir annehmen,
dass das Universum sich beschleunigt, ausdehnt.
Und wenn man das dann zusammennimmt, dann hat man das Gefühl,
das Bild wird wieder konsistent.
Also die Ergebnisse passen zusammen. Wir haben eigentlich die Bausteine schon in der Theorie.
Unser Problem ist mehr, dass wir nicht verstehen, wo die herkommen.
Also diese kosmologische Konstante, die Einstein eingeführt hat,
das ist zunächst einmal eine dimensionslose Zahl. Warum ist die da?
Warum hat die den Wert? Warum ist die nicht null?
Und dann versuchen sie zu verstehen, wie kann ich sowas auf mikroskopischer
Skala erzeugen und das ist Quantenfeldtheorie, das ist Heisenberg,
und dann stellen sie fest, das passt alles nicht zusammen und dann haben sie
eigentlich ein Bild, was sich entwickelt in eine Richtung, dass sie das Gefühl
haben, das wird alles konsistent,
wenn ich gewisse Annahmen mache, aber die Grundlagen für die Annahmen fehlen mir.
Also müssen wir verstehen, welche Grundlagen brauchen wir, um diese Annahmen zu rechtfertigen.
Denn man sollte ja auch wieder, wenn man in der Geschichte zurückgeht,
als Michelson und Morley die Konstante der Lichtgeschwindigkeit gemessen hatten,
da haben die das gemessen, weil wir davon ausgingen, dass das Licht,
also elektromagnetische Wellen, ein Medium brauchen, um sich auszudehnen.
Und das haben wir Äther genannt.
Und wenn es diesen Äther tatsächlich geben würde und die Lichtwellen sich in
diesem Äther ausbreiten, dann müsste es einen Unterschied machen,
ob ich das Licht also in Richtung der Flugbahn der Erde um die Sonne aussende
oder entgegengesetzt dazu.
Und Michelson und Morley haben gezeigt, das macht keinen Unterschied, den Äther gibt es nicht.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt ein Modell des Universums machen und sagen,
dafür brauchen wir aber Inflation, Vakuumenergie, also dunkle Energie, dunkle Materie,
dann ist ja die Frage, sind das Hilfskonstrukte, die wir einführen,
weil wir nicht verstanden haben, wie es wirklich funktioniert?
Oder gibt es diese Sachen wirklich? Also ist die Aufgabe der Experimentalphysik,
das kann ja sonst keiner machen, also Experimentalphysiker müssen versuchen
zu verstehen, was ist das?
Was sind das neue Elementarteilchen bei der dunklen Materie?
Was ist das? Sind das schwarze Löcher?
Sind das braune Zwerge? Also sowas wie der Jupiter, also was massiv genug ist,
um Masse zu haben, also viel Masse zu haben, aber nicht massiv genug, um zu leuchten.
Sind das weiße Zwerge, also Überbleibsel von, nicht von Supernova-Explosionen,
aber von Nova-Explosionen, Endstadium von Sternenentwicklung,
die wir nicht sehen, weil die halt nicht leuchten.
Ist es interstellares Medium, was wir nicht richtig verstehen.
Das heißt, sie gehen dann durch die Physikprozesse durch, versuchen das zu verstehen
und dann kommen wir zu dem Ergebnis, nichts von dem, was wir können,
ist in der Lage, das zu beschreiben.
Also die Neutrinos als Elementarteilchen sind nicht in der Lage,
dunkle Materie vernünftig zu beschreiben.
Wir können ausschließen, dass weiße Zwerge, braune Zwerge, schwarze Löcher die dunkle Materie sind.
Weil die nicht genug Materie darstellen könnten?
Nein, weil wir verstehen, dass die bekannten Materieformen, also ich nenne da,
also der Fachbegriff ist baryonische Materie. Was ist das?
Das sind also, das ist Materie, die aus Atomkernen aufgebaut sind.
Also wir bestehen alle aus Atomen.
Das Atom besteht aus Atomkernen und Elektronen, was da drum herum fliegt.
Oder Elektronen, je nach Ladung des Kerns.
Der Kern selber besteht aus Protonen und Neutronen. So einen Protonen und Neutronen
bezeichnen wir als Baryonen. Alle chemischen Elemente sind aus Baryonen.
Protonen und Neutronen.
Und bis vor kurzer Zeit war das eigentlich so die Sicht auf die Welt,
dass alles daraus besteht?
Die Sicht auf die Welt ist immer noch, dass alle Materie daraus besteht.
Wir können aufgrund der Häufigkeit der chemischen Elemente im Universum heute
ausrechnen, dass nicht mehr baryonische Materie produziert worden ist am Anfang.
Das heißt, selbst wenn die dann in braunen Zwergen, weißen Zwergen oder schwarzen
Löcher als Endstadium von Sternen jetzt drin ist, dann reicht das nicht aus,
dass wir damit die dunkle Materie hinkriegen. Das heißt, wir brauchen neue Elementarteilchen.
Und von der dunklen Materie weiß man eigentlich nur deshalb oder meint zu wissen,
weil sonst die ganzen Zusammenhänge mit Gravitation etc. keinen Sinn mehr ergeben.
Genau, wir haben das Gravitationsgesetz getestet. Also wir sind in der Lage
zu beschreiben, wie die Erde um die Sonne kreist, wie Jupiter,
Saturn, Venus, Merkur, selbst Merkur im Detail, der durch ein sehr starkes Gravitationsfeld
durch muss und deshalb einige Eigenheiten hat, die wir beobachten können.
Es hat einen Nobelpreis gegeben für die Beobachtung von einem Pulsar,
bei dem man also beobachtet hat, wie die Periode, die Rotationsperiode von diesem
Neutronenstern sich verändert.
Das passt hervorragend zur Relativitätstheorie. Das heißt also,
in den letzten 50 Jahren haben wir die einsteinische Gravitationstheorie im
Detail mit immer größerer Präzision getestet.
Ihr Navigationssystem, was ich am Anfang gesandt habe, wäre jedes Mal um 20
Kilometer falsch, ohne Einsteins allgemeine Relativitätstheorie.
Auch Einstein hätte Ihnen das nicht vorhersagen können, dass Sie mal mit seiner
Theorie ein Navigationssystem machen.
Aber für uns ist das heute Alltag. Wir benutzen das und wir sehen,
dass das mit guter Präzision funktioniert.
Und dann ist die Annahme in den Naturwissenschaften immer, die einfachste Theorie ist die beste.
Und das heißt, wir haben eine Theorie der Gravitation, die funktioniert.
Wir haben aber Phänomene, die wir nicht beschreiben können.
Also muss es eine Erweiterung dieser Theorie geben. Wie sieht die aus?
Auf diese Fragen versuchen wir Antworten zu finden und wir wissen,
dass wir also nicht in der Lage sind, den Anfangszustand des Universums zu beschreiben.
Also Urknall kriegen wir nicht hin, schwarze Löcher kriegen wir nicht hin,
weil in diesen Fällen dieses Modell von Einstein einfach zusammenbricht.
Die Gleichungen sind divergent, also wie die Mathematiker sagen,
das heißt, da kommt unendlich raus und damit kann ich nichts anfangen.
Habt keine Vorhersagekraft mehr. Also da passiert was, was wir nicht verstehen.
Und das ist im Moment der Schlüssel, wie wir versuchen, da weiterzukommen.
Das heißt, die Frage jetzt für uns ist, welche Experimente können wir machen,
um zu verstehen, was dunkle Materie und dunkle Energie sind.
Und das ist der Grund, warum wir also gesagt haben, wir brauchen ein Experiment auf der Raumstation.
Wir können das also nicht mit terrestrischen Experimenten machen,
weil wir uns Phänomene angucken wollen, Wollen die also was mit den Grundlagen
dessen zu tun haben, wie dieses Universum aufgebaut ist, entstanden ist und
wie die physikalischen Zusammenhänge bei der Entwicklung sind?
Jetzt sind wir schon wieder bei dem Uns, was die RWTH in diesem Lehrstuhl beschreibt.
Zwischendurch gab es viel Uns, was so eigentlich die gesamte Welt der Physik betrifft.
Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass nur hier jetzt an diesem Problem gearbeitet werden würde.
Etwas, was viel Wind gemacht hat in letzter Zeit und auch immer noch viel abstrahlt,
ist das LHC-Experiment im CERN, dieser riesige Beschleunigungsring,
bei dem ja im Prinzip eigentlich auch dieselbe Fragestellung dahinter steht, oder?
Ja, also es gibt, erstmal es gibt sehr viele Wissenschaftler,
was gut ist, die an diesen Fragestellungen arbeiten.
Also um das nochmal so ein bisschen einzuordnen, also das AMS-Experiment ist
von 60 Forschungsinstituten entwickelt worden.
Die RWTH Aachen war eins davon. Da sind 600 Wissenschaftler dann beteiligt,
nicht 20 in Aachen, die sowas machen können. Also das ist die richtige Skala dann.
Also uns ist, manchmal ist das der RWTH-Physiker, uns seine Gruppe,
manchmal sind das alle Physiker, manchmal ist das die ganze Menschheit, je nachdem.
Ich fühle mich zu allen zugehörig. Ja, natürlich.
Jetzt, wenn wir das versuchen einzuordnen, wie ist so der Zusammenhang mit den
anderen grundlegenden Experimenten in der Physik, die zurzeit laufen?
Dann ist der Versuch am CERN, an dem LHC-Beschleuniger, an dessen Forschungsprogramm
wir hier auch beteiligt sind, also wir ist jetzt RWTH Aachen, ich insbesondere.
Dann ist der
ansatz am zern eigentlich dass wir versuchen die
neuen elementarteilchen die wir suchen zu erzeugen
im labor das heißt wir machen kollisionen von von hoch energetischen protonen
und schauen uns die zerfallsprodukte an die dabei erzeugt werden und versuchen
zu verstehen wie die wechselwirkung am anfang aussah also bei diesen kollisionen
man könnte sagen wir Wir versuchen, so einen kleinen Urknall im Labor zu machen.
Wir sind natürlich um größten Ordnungen von den Energien weg,
die am Urknall wirklich geherrscht haben.
Aber wir versuchen, uns dem anzunähern und zu verstehen, welche physikalischen
Prozesse sind notwendig, um das zu beschreiben.
Und treten dabei neue Phänomene auf, insbesondere neue Elementarteilchen,
die in Frage kommen, um zum Beispiel dunkle Materie zu beschreiben.
Unser Problem bei diesen Experimenten ist,
Wenn wir da ein neues Elementarteilchen finden, dann steht da nicht dran,
ich bin dunkle Materie, sondern steht da im besten Fall dran,
ich bin ein neues Elementarteilchen, verstehe mich.
Und verstehe mich heißt dann, in dem Labor können wir die Bedingungen während
der Kollision kontrollieren, das heißt wir können die Energie verändern,
wir können bestimmte Eigenschaften der Teilchen versuchen zu verändern und versuchen
zu verstehen, was das ist.
Und das war in den letzten 50
Jahren, seitdem wir also an Beschleunigern arbeiten, extrem erfolgreich.
Wir haben viel über die Wechselwirkung und die Kräfte in der Natur dabei gelernt, das so zu tun.
Wenn wir jetzt aber ein neues Teilchen finden, und das soll dunkle Materie sein
im Universum, dann brauche ich ein anderes Experiment, was auch in der Lage
ist, die Eigenschaften dieser Teilchen zu messen, was aber im Weltraum ist.
Und sagt, ich schaffe die Verbindung.
Um im Bild zu sein, ich messe sowas wie einen Fingerabdruck von diesem Teilchen an dem Beschleuniger.
Das heißt, ich messe seine Eigenschaften.
Und ich messe die gleichen Eigenschaften im Weltraum. Und wenn die Eigenschaften
zusammenpassen, dann habe ich verstanden, was ich da habe.
Und das ist die Verbindung zwischen der Physik, die wir auf der Raumstation
machen, und der Physik, die wir an Beschleunigerexperimenten machen.
Womit wir so ein bisschen beim eigentlichen Thema angekommen sind,
das Alpha-Magnet-Spektrometer oder kurz AMS gab es bisher in zwei Varianten.
Ein AMS-01, was eher so der Testballon war und jetzt noch in Betrieb seit 2011,
das AMS-02 auf der Raumstation.
Wann ist denn die Idee für dieses Projekt geboren worden und was soll das jetzt konkret tun?
Also wie soll diese eigentliche Aufgabe, man muss das auch im Weltraum mal messen
können, wie ist man da rangegangen und wo hat sich diese Idee überhaupt herausgebildet?
Ja, das ist also eine recht komplexe Frage.
Ich fange mal mit dem ersten Teil an. Wie hat sich das entwickelt?
Wer ist auf die Idee gekommen?
Vom 1995 hatten wir also die Situation, dass wir Beschleunigerexperimente am
CERN in Genf gemacht haben, an einem sehr ähnlichen Beschleuniger.
Der war in dem gleichen Tunnel eingebaut, hat aber Elektronen und Positronen
zur Kollision gebracht.
Und wir waren in der Situation, dass wir uns gefragt haben, was machen wir danach?
Und dann gab es also eine Richtung der Teilchenphysik, die haben gesagt,
wir ersetzen die Elektronen und Positronen in Beschleuniger durch Protonen.
Dann können wir höhere Energien erreichen, Schwerpunktsenergien und damit neue
Teilchen produzieren und neue Phänomene verstehen.
Und eine andere Gruppe hat gesagt, eigentlich die höchsten energetischen Beschleuniger
im Universum, das sind Supernova-Explosionen.
Also das kann ich auf der Erde nicht nachbauen. Also so viel Energie,
wie frei wird, wenn ein Stern explodiert, das kann ich auf der Erde nicht nachbauen.
Und es gibt noch hochenergetischer, das nennen wir aktive galaktische Kerne,
wo Teilchen auf noch höhere Energien beschleunigt werden können.
Und wenn Sie sich die Entwicklung in der modernen Physik angucken,
dann sind viele Erkenntnisse, die wir haben, aus der Beobachtung der kosmischen
Höhenstrahlung entstanden.
Die ersten Elementarteilchen sind da gefunden worden. Also das Antiteilchen
zum Elektron, das Positron ist da gefunden worden.
Myonen sind in der kosmischen Strahlung gefunden worden. Pionen.
Am Anfang hat es dafür noch Nobelpreise gegeben, weil man dachte,
das ist es jetzt. Es gibt vielleicht zwei, drei. Dann hat sich herausgestellt, das ist ein ganzer Zoo.
Und dann hat man in den 50er Jahren gesagt, also wisst ihr was,
die Rate in der kosmischen Strahlung ist zu klein. Wir bauen Beschleuniger.
Und dann studieren wir das.
Was heißt denn, man hat das in der kosmischen Höhenstrahlung gefunden?
Wo musste man sich denn befinden?
Ja, das ist also wirklich teilweise abenteuerlich.
Also die Leute haben Fotoemulsionen genommen und die Flugbahnen von den Teilchen
in diesen Fotoemulsionen gesehen und damit die Eigenschaften verstanden.
Das ging so weit, dass die, also die moderne Elektronik gab es ja nicht,
also Sintillationszähler, das ist also ein Plastikmaterial, da geht ein Teilchen
durch und erzeugt Licht.
Und wir lesen das heute mit elektronischen Geräten aus und zählen die Lichtblitze
und verstehen, was da passiert.
Aber die haben sich dann Kisten gebaut, die Sintillationszähler da reingetan
und haben sich in die Kisten gesetzt. Und die war absolut dunkel.
Und dann haben sie lang genug gewartet.
Nach mehreren Stunden ist das Auge so empfindlich, dass sie also diese Lichtblitze
dann auch so sehen können und zählen können.
Also Physik ist manchmal mühsam.
Und das Ergebnis war, es gibt also einen ganzen Zoo von Elementarteilchen.
Wie kriege ich den jetzt irgendwie sortiert? und das haben dann die Beschleunigerexperimente gemacht.
Und nochmal zu Verständnis, diese kosmische Strahlung prasselt ohnehin die ganze Zeit auf uns ein.
Also dazu muss man sich jetzt gar nicht auf Mount Everest begeben,
sondern es reicht auch in der Straße stehen zu bleiben und sozusagen nur im
richtigen Moment hinzugucken.
Die ist auch nicht so ganz unwesentlich dafür, dass es uns überhaupt gibt.
Also entdeckt worden ist sie von Victor Hess, auch wieder vor 100 Jahren,
Also in diesem Jahr vor 100 Jahren,
also genau vor 100 Jahren mit einem Ballonflug in der Nähe von Wien.
Der ist mit dem Ballon aufgestiegen und hat gemessen, wie viele elektrische
Teilchen er sieht, also geladene Teilchen er sieht und sich gewundert, dass das mehr werden.
Also eigentlich war er der Meinung, die kommen von der Erde.
Ja, und dann ist er aufgestiegen und hat gemerkt, das werden immer mehr.
Und dann war klar, die kommen eigentlich von oben.
Keine Erdstrahlen.
Keine Erdstrahlen. Dann ist die Frage, was ist das?
Das sind Teilchen, die in kosmischen Beschleunigern wie einer Supernova-Explosion
auf hohe Energien beschleunigt werden und auf die Erdatmosphäre treffen.
Und die Erdatmosphäre schützt uns vor denen. Also wenn Sie Raumfahrt machen
und Sie nehmen also einen Astronauten und schicken den zum Mars,
dann wird er das wahrscheinlich nicht überleben. Er wird an Krebs sterben.
Entweder schon während des Fluges oder kurz nachdem er hier auf der Erde gelandet
ist, weil die Strahlung einfach viel zu hoch ist. Die Erde ist ein sehr geschütztes Reservoir.
Wir haben ein Erdmagnetfeld und eine Erdatmosphäre, die uns vor dieser kosmischen Strahlung schützt.
Auf der Raumstation sind wir immer noch im Erdmagnetfeld und wir werden zur
Hälfte durch den Erdschatten abgedeckt.
Wenn Sie aber ein freifliegendes Raumschiff haben, dann ist die Strahlung das
größte Problem. Also Leben, Leute dahin zu bringen.
Wie viel Prozent schirmt die Erde ab? Wie viel kommt trotzdem noch durch?
Also es kommt so wenig durch, dass Sie zwar interessante Sachen darin finden
können, aber wenn Sie verstehen wollen, was kommt also primär,
dann müssen Sie bei den niedrigen Energien in den Weltraum gehen.
Dann werden zwar die Teilchen durch das Erdmagnetfeld abgelenkt, aber nicht verändert.
Bei sehr hohen Energien gibt es also Experimente, die benutzen die Erdatmosphäre,
damit die Teilchen also einen sogenannten Teilchenschauer in der Erdatmosphäre
erzeugen, wie das Pierre Auger Observatorium in Argentinien.
Und gucken sich diese Schauer, also die Sekundärteilchen an,
die da angekommen sind, um Informationen über das Primärteilchen zu erlangen.
Bei AMS ist der Ansatz ein anderer. Wir verlassen die Erdatmosphäre,
weil wir uns angucken wollen, was also sozusagen ungestört von der Erdatmosphäre hier ankommt.
Aber um den Gedanken noch eben zu Ende zu bringen, wenn wir keine kosmische
Strahlung hätten, dann hätten wir wahrscheinlich keine vernünftige Evolution hingekriegt.
Denn diese kosmische Strahlung verursacht natürlich in einigen Fällen,
wenigen Fällen zum Glück, aber genügend Fällen Schäden in dem Erbgut,
die eine Evolution in Gang setzen können. Also wenn sie das Erbgut immer nur
perfekt kopieren, kriegen sie keine Evolution hin.
Wenn sie zu viel kosmische Strahlung haben, dann ist die Schädigung zu groß
und sie können auch nicht überleben. Sie sterben an Krebs.
Ja, es ist ein sehr fein tariertes Gleichgewicht.
Fortschritt durch Mutation.
Fortschritt durch Mutation, ja. Ohne Mutation gibt es keinen Fortschritt.
Also das ist nicht angenehm, aber so ist es.
Und die Idee von AMS ist, wir schauen uns das im Weltraum an,
wir gehen zurück zu den Anfängen der Teilchenphysik, wir machen Experimente
mit den höchsten energetischen Teilchen, die es gibt und wir machen das in einem
Bereich, wo wir die Anfangsbedingungen nicht kontrollieren können.
Also bei dem Beschleuniger kontrollieren Sie ja die Anfangsbedingungen.
Das heißt, Sie können die Wechselwirkungsrate einstellen, die Energie einstellen.
Da oben sehen wir alles, was es gibt.
Was nicht heißt, dass wir merken, was es ist und dass wir das alles verstehen
können. Aber wir haben keine Einschränkungen an den Anfangszustand.
Und das ist die spannende Idee bei AMS. Und dann haben sich die Gründungsväter
von AMS, zu denen ich nicht gehöre, weil 1995 war ich also gerade mit meiner Promotion fertig.
Da war ich noch nicht in der Position, um also solche Experimente vorzuschlagen.
Das ist vorgeschlagen worden von Herrn Professor Ting.
Der ist Professor am MIT in den USA, hat den Nobelpreis für Physik in den 70er
Jahren bekommen für die Entdeckung eines neuen Elementarteilchens.
Als es noch Nobelpreise dafür gab?
Dafür noch Nobelpreise gab. Das war der letzte Nobelpreis, den es für die Entdeckung
eines Quarks gegeben hat, das Charmquark.
Der hat das vorgeschlagen, sich eine Gruppe von Mitstreitern gesucht.
Dazu gehörte mein Vorgänger hier in Aachen, Herr Professor Lübbelsmeier,
der dieses Experiment auf den Weg gebracht hat. und die Idee war eigentlich ganz einfach.
Wir gehen also aus der Erstatmosphäre raus und wir sind damit in der Lage,
uns Teilchen anzugucken, die sich bisher keiner angucken konnte.
Aber das Magnetfeld greift ja immer noch.
Das Magnetfeld greift immer noch und das greift auch vorher schon.
Das heißt, wir verlieren die Richtungsinformation.
Wenn Sie sich angucken, was wissen wir vom Universum, dann wissen wir das im
Wesentlichen aus der Beobachtung der neutralen Teilchen.
Das heißt also der Photon und der Neutrinos heute. Bei den Teilchen behalten
Sie die Richtungsinformationen.
Das heißt, Sie können die Quelle identifizieren.
Also Licht.
Licht, das sind die Photonen. Neutrinos in jüngerer Zeit mit Detektoren.
Bei den geladenen Teilchen, die werden schon von den galaktischen Magnetfeldern abgelenkt.
Die werden durch Turbulenzen abgelenkt in dem interstellaren Medium.
Das heißt, die Richtungsinformationen haben wir nicht mehr.
Aber um mal ein Beispiel zu sagen, wenn wir uns angucken, wie das Universum
entstanden ist, dann gehen wir davon aus, dass es vor dem Universum eigentlich nichts gab.
Also, sonst wäre es ja nicht der Anfang. Ja. Wenn es nichts gab,
dann kommt man zu der Idee, dass nichts müsste eigentlich elektrisch neutral sein.
Sonst ist es ja nicht nichts. Also wenn es eine elektrische Ladung hat,
dann ist es ja schon was. Also es hat keine elektrische Ladung.
Alle Versuche, die wir machen heute, zeigen uns, dass genauso viele positive
wie negative Teilchen dann produziert werden. Genauso viel Materie wie Antimaterie.
Heute verstehen wir nicht, wie es dazu kommt, dass diese vier Prozent,
die wir beobachten an Materie im Universum, dass das nur Materie ist.
Was ist mit der Antimaterie passiert?
Es könnte durchaus sein, dass es Bereiche gibt im Universum,
die aus Antimaterie bestehen. Vielleicht ist das Ganze symmetrisch.
Es gibt Antimaterie-Galaxien.
Was ist Antimaterie nochmal?
Was ist Antimaterie? Also ich hatte versucht zu erklären, wie so ein Atom aufgebaut ist.
Das hat ein einfaches Atom, Wasserstoffatom, Atomkern, ist ein Proton und ein Elektronkreis darum.
Die Physik sagt aber, das muss völlig symmetrisch sein.
Es muss also ein Anti-Wasserstoffatom geben, was aus einem Antiproton,
dem Antiteilchen zum Proton, und einem Positron besteht, dem Antiteilchen zum Elektron.
So, das hat Dirac postuliert, aufgrund von theoretischen Überlegungen.
Und in der kosmischen Höhenstrahlung ist dann das Positron gefunden worden,
das Antiteilchen zum Elektron.
Das heißt, das hat dieselben Eigenschaften wie das Elektron,
nur die entgegengesetzte elektrische Ladung.
So, und wenn dieses Universum am Anfang genauso viel Materie wie Antimaterie
hatte, dann ist die Frage,
wo ist die Antimaterie geblieben, gibt es Bereiche aus Antimaterie und wenn
wir jetzt mit dem AMS-Experiment einen einzigen Antikohlenstoffkern sehen, dann wissen wir,
es gibt Sterne aus Antimaterie, denn Kohlenstoff kann nur in Sternen entstehen,
also es gibt Sterne aus Antimaterie im Universum und wir können dann nicht sagen, wo der ist.
Weil wir die Richtungsinformation nicht haben. Aber die Erkenntnis an sich,
dass es Bereiche im Universum aus Antimaterie gibt, würde also die Physik komplett revolutionieren.
Und das ist nur eine der Facetten, die sich AMS anguckt.
Und mit diesen Überlegungen, es ist also, selbst wenn wir die Richtungsinformation
nicht bekommen können, das liegt ja nicht daran, dass wir das Experiment irgendwie
schlecht machen, sondern dass die Natur dafür gesorgt hat,
dass diese Richtungsinformation nicht mehr vorhanden ist, gibt es genug physikalische
Fragen, die interessant genug sind, dass wir uns das mit solch einem Experiment
angucken können. Und das war die Geburtsstunde von AMS.
Das ist also eine Veröffentlichung, wo in Größenordnung 50 Personen draufstehen,
von Aachen, Herr Lübbelsmeier als Institutsleiter damals.
Und dann haben die Raumfahrtagenturen gesagt, also ihr seid Teilchenphysiker.
Wir glauben euch, dass ihr Experimente am CERN bauen könnt.
Aber so ein Experiment in den Weltraum zu bringen, ist schon noch ein bisschen was anderes.
Anderes. Und ihr müsst uns erstmal zeigen, dass sowas funktioniert.
Und das war die Idee von AMS1. Die Idee von AMS1 war, einen Prototypen zu bauen,
mit dem man zeigen kann, sowas kann man überhaupt machen.
Also Teilchendetektoren sind ja sehr empfindliche Messinstrumente.
Größenordnung zu geben, wir messen also die Flugbahnen von Teilchen durch solch
ein Instrument mit einer Genauigkeit von tausendstel Millimeter.
Tausendstel Millimeter. Jetzt überlegen Sie sich mal, wie Sie was bauen müssen,
dass Sie das vom Tisch schmeißen können.
Und das kann danach immer noch tausendstel Millimeter messen.
Und das vom Tisch schmeißen ist der Start mit dem Space Shuttle.
Das ist der vorsichtigste Start, den Sie überhaupt haben können in der Raumfahrt.
Das sind extreme Anforderungen von der Technologie. Das zweite Problem,
was es zu lösen galt, war, die Erde hat ja zum Glück ein Magnetfeld.
Wenn Sie jetzt geladene Teilchen messen wollen, brauchen Sie selber einen Magneten.
Weil nur mit einem Magneten können Sie die geladenen Teilchen ablenken und aus
der Ablenkung den Impuls und die elektrische Ladung messen.
Wenn Sie diesen Magneten aber nicht sehr sorgfältig auslegen,
dann starten Sie das Space Shuttle und danach haben Sie sämtliche Lagekontrolle verloren.
Weil dieser Magnetwechsel wirkt mit dem Erdmagnetfeld und genau wie eine Kompassnadel
dreht sich dann das Shuttle bei seinen 90 Minuten um die Erde die ganze Zeit
in dem Erdmagnetfeld und sie können gar nichts mehr tun.
Und da gab es in den 80er Jahren eine Entwicklung, dass also Physiker,
Festkörperphysiker sich aus ganz anderen Gründen mit Magnetfeldern auseinandergesetzt
haben und ein Konzept vorgeschlagen haben, wie man solch einen Magneten bauen kann.
Und dieses Konzept hat AMS umgesetzt mit einem sogenannten Permanentmagneten.
Er ist also aus seltenen Erden aufgebaut.
Ist auch an sich schon ein faszinierendes Projekt. Also die seltenen Erden kamen
aus China nach Deutschland gegangen zur Vakuumschmelze.
Vakuumschmelze hat daraus kleine Würfelchen gemacht.
Also die seltenen Erden sind eigentlich Metalle.
Ja.
Man sagt es halt so, was selten ist.
Ja, aber es sind halt Metalle mit bestimmten Eigenschaften.
Vakuumschmelze hat also die magnetisiert und kleine Würfelchen draus gemacht,
muss man sich vorstellen, so Kubikzentimeter groß.
Und die haben dann eine bevorzugte Magnetisierungsrichtung schon und daraus
wollen sie also einen zylindrischen Magneten zusammenbauen.
Aus Würfeln kann ich keinen Zylinder bauen. Da gibt es immer Lücken.
Also sind diese Würfelchen in Deutschland produziert, wieder nach China gegangen
und jeder einzelne Würfel ist in Form geschnitten worden, dass ich daraus also
passgenau einen Zylinder bauen kann. Dafür brauchen sie sehr viel Personal.
Deshalb macht man das lieber in China. Das können sie nicht mit Maschinen machen, vernünftig.
Diese seltenen Erden, wenn die gepresst sind, sind also extrem brüchig.
Versuchen sie mal ein Keramikmesser zu schleifen. Also besser versuchen sie
es nicht. Das bricht in der Regel ab.
Das war also extrem arbeitsintensiv, aber ist in China dann gemacht worden.
Und die NASA war die Raumfahrtagentur, die das begleitet hat.
Und die hat ihre Ingenieure nach China geschickt, um den Prozess zu überwachen
und hat dann gesagt, so und jetzt wollen wir auskriegen, hält dieser Magnet
auch einen Start mit einem Space Shuttle aus.
Und das Einzige, was sie dann machen können, ist, um sich wirklich davon zu
überzeugen, dass sie zwei Baugleiche machen und den einen versuchen kaputt zu machen.
Also einen Distractive Test Test, wie das so schön heißt, also einen Test bis
zur Zerstörung, um wirklich rauszukriegen, wo sind die Grenzen in der Festigkeit.
Und der Prüfbericht von dem NASA-Ingenieur, der das gemacht hatte,
ist sehr instruktiv, der sagt nämlich, wir geben auf.
Also wir haben alles Equipment, was uns eingefallen ist, versucht zu verwenden
und wir können diesen Ring nicht kaputt kriegen, diesen Zylinder.
Obwohl das eigentlich so ein brüchiges Material ist.
Ja, aber wenn das also in solch einer Metallmatrix verklebt ist,
dann ist das ein extrem robustes Objekt und diese Metallmatrix müssen sie sehr
robust auslegen, denn die magnetischen Kräfte, die da wirken,
sind viel größer als die mechanischen Kräfte bei dem Start von dem Space Shuttle.
Das Ding hält sich sozusagen selbst zusammen.
Ja, das ist so ähnlich wie ein Gewölbe, was Sie bauen, wenn Sie den Stein in
die richtige Form geben und das zusammensetzen oder eine Brücke,
können Sie da drüber gehen und das fällt nicht ein zusammen.
So, und das heißt, damit ist es gelungen, dann solch einen Magneten zu bauen,
das Magnetfeld so auszulegen, dass es also in der Fachsprache heißt,
kein externes Dipolmoment hat.
Das geht physikalisch nicht, aber ein so kleines, dass dieses externe Dipolmoment
nicht mit dem Erdmagnetfeld wechselwirkt.
Und dann ist 1998 mit dem Space Shuttle Discovery dieser Prototyp geflogen.
Schaut man sich mal die Zeitskala an, das ist drei Jahre nach dem Vorschlag.
Also wenn wir heute Raumfahrtprojekte machen, dann können wir nur davon träumen,
dass also von der Idee bis zur Ausführung drei Jahre vergehen.
Das war sehr erfolgreich, sind viele wissenschaftliche Veröffentlichungen rausgekommen
und dann haben die Raumfahrtagenturen gesagt, so und jetzt habt ihr gezeigt,
das funktioniert, jetzt baut was für die Raumstation.
Drei Jahre. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich schnell. Was hat dazu geführt.
Dass das möglich war?
Also erstmal muss man sehen, dass das vor den Abstürzen der Space Shuttle war.
Das heißt, die Sicherheitsanforderungen waren noch andere. Die Leute waren nicht
so sensibilisiert für Sicherheitsfragen.
Heute können sie das alleine schon deshalb nicht schaffen, selbst wenn sie alles
richtig machen, sie können nicht nachweisen, dass alles richtig ist.
Also der Aufwand an Dokumentation und an Testverfahren ist so groß geworden
jetzt, dass sie das in der Zeit einfach gar nicht schaffen können.
Das ist der eine Grund. Und der zweite Grund, die Teilchenphysiker arbeiten
anders als die Raumfahrtindustrie und als die, wie soll man das sagen,
auch die Raumfahrtagenturen.
Also die, Goldin war zu der Zeit der Chef von der NASA und der hat gesagt,
also wenn ich das intern hinkriegen würde, sowas, das wäre unglaublich.
Ja, die Teilchenphysiker, die waren gewohnt, Experimente zu bauen,
das heißt, wir haben diese Infrastruktur an den Universitäten,
das heißt also, so ein physikalisches Institut in Aachen hat eine große Werkstatt,
Mechanik, Elektronik inklusive Entwicklung.
Ähm, das heißt, es war relativ leicht möglich, ein großes Team von Wissenschaftlern,
Technikern sozusagen aus dem Stand zur Verfügung zu haben mit dem richtigen
Know-how, um das zu machen.
Und das Zweite war, die Raumfahrtagenturen selber haben das sehr geschickt gemanagt.
Die haben nämlich gesagt, also die können Instrumente bauen. Das glauben wir denen.
Raumfahrt kennen sie nicht. Also wir setzen ein Ingenieurbüro ein an der Schnittstelle,
was diesen Prozess überwacht, an deren Treffen teilnimmt, an deren Arbeitsbesprechungen
teilnimmt und denen unmittelbar eine Rückmeldung gibt, ob das,
was die sich überlegen, Sinn macht oder keinen Sinn macht.
Und zwar nicht, wie das so schön neudeutsch heißt, vor dem Hintergrund Mission
Success, sondern nur Mission Safety.
Also der Erfolg der Mission ist Aufgabe der Wissenschaftler.
Aber die Sicherheit der Mission ist unsere Aufgabe und darauf konzentrieren wir uns.
Und alles, was damit nichts zu tun hat, das lassen wir die Wissenschaftler machen,
das machen die vor Ort, das machen die schnell und das funktioniert.
So, und dann hat sich also die ETH Zürich bereit erklärt, sozusagen die gesamte
Integration, dass die in Zürich passiert. Also ein Instrument ist recht komplex.
Das ist da gemacht worden und dann ist das von Zürich mit einer 747 zum Kennedy
Space Center geflogen worden und mit dem Space Shuttle Discovery geflogen worden.
Und das war ein Erfolg, was für ein so dreijähriges Projekt also schon ein gutes Aushängeschild ist.
Wer hat denn das finanziert?
Und was wir damals im Wesentlichen gemacht haben, sind Tragestrukturen,
Kohlefasertragestrukturen zu bauen, zu entwickeln.
Und etwas, was sich Laser Alignment System nennt, das ist also ein optisches
System, was die mechanische Stabilität dieses Instruments überwacht hat.
Das war also von deutscher Seite recht bescheiden. Im Wesentlichen finanziert
worden ist das von Schweizer Seite, ETH Zürich.
Die Schweizer Gruppen haben viel finanziert und das MIT über Herrn Ting,
Italien, das waren die wesentlichen Geldgeber. Mhm.
Das war jetzt aber auch noch, sagen wir mal, ein vergleichsweise kleineres Experiment-Setup
im Vergleich zu dem, was dann später kam.
Wie groß muss man sich das Ding vorstellen?
AMS 1 oder AMS 2?
Nee, die erste.
AMS 1 würde ich sagen, ein bisschen mehr als ein Kubikmeter instrumentiertes Volumen.
So was wie zweieinhalb bis drei Tonnen Gewicht.
Also schon eine signifikante Last.
Also für Raumfahrt, wenn man sich anguckt, was der Aufwand ist,
um ein Kilogramm Material auf die Raumstation zu bringen, das ist schon ein
signifikanter Teil des Materials und das war in dem Flug auch die wesentliche
Nutzlast von dem Space Shuttle.
Das hatte als sonstige Aufgabe zum ersten Mal an die Mira anzudocken und hat
dieses Experiment halt mitgeflogen.
Also bei AMS 2 sind die Dimensionen jetzt ein bisschen anders.
Da haben wir so 60 Kubikmeter instrumentiertes Volumen.
Also 5 mal 4 mal 3 Meter ist das Ganze groß, wiegt knapp 8 Tonnen,
braucht zweieinhalb Kilowatt Strom.
Das ist also schon eine Nummer größer, eine Nummer aufwendiger.
Aber mit den Erfahrungen von AMS1 war das auch vertretbar.
In der wissenschaftlichen Entwicklung, Sie können normalerweise eine Größenordnung
extrapolieren, das funktioniert, also ein Faktor 10.
Faktor 100 ist schwierig, also da tauchen normalerweise ganz andere Probleme auf.
Und der Vergleich zwischen AMS 1 und AMS 2 ist so grob, also groben Faktor 10.
Ja, an einigen Stellen ist es mehr, an anderen Stellen ist es weniger,
aber grob ist es also eine Größenordnung schwieriger als AMS 1 zu machen.
Bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei AMS 1. Also was konnte da jetzt konkret getan werden
und was konnte bewiesen werden?
Also, zunächst einmal war die Hauptaufgabe zu zeigen, dass man so ein Instrument
in den Weltraum bringen kann. Also eine technische Frage.
Das heißt, die Hauptfrage war, seid ihr in der Lage, das zu bauen?
Wir fliegen das und dann kommt das wieder runter und das funktioniert immer noch.
Und hat sich nicht so verändert, dass dadurch eure Messergebnisse beeinflusst werden.
Das mussten wir also nachweisen. Das heißt, nach dem Flug ist das Instrument
in einen sogenannten Teststrahl gegangen, wieder am CERN und an der GSI in Darmstadt.
Und wir haben uns mit bekannten Teilchen angeguckt, dass das immer noch genauso
funktioniert wie vor dem Start.
Das heißt, die Ergebnisse ließen sich auch erst nach Rückkehr der Mission überhaupt auslesen?
Die Ergebnisse kommen immer erst nach Rückkehr. Also die Daten werden da aufgezeichnet.
Wir haben 100 Millionen Teilchen aus der kosmischen Höhenstrahlung aufgezeichnet.
Das war damals also so die größte Datenmenge, die man hatte, primär gemessen.
In zehn Tagen.
In zehn Tagen Flug.
Wir haben dabei, also ich will zwei wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse sagen.
Also wir haben zum einen natürlich nach Antimaterien der kosmischen Strahlung gesucht.
Wir haben keine gefunden. Jetzt kann man sagen, das ist schlecht.
Eigentlich ist das doch nur ein Erfolg, wenn ihr was findet.
Aber jetzt gehe ich wieder zurück zu dem Experiment von Michelson und Morley.
Die haben nicht gefunden, dass die Lichtgeschwindigkeit sich ändert.
Die haben gefunden, dass die Lichtgeschwindigkeit sich nicht ändert.
Das war die Erkenntnis. Wir haben keine Antimaterie gefunden.
Wir haben damit die Erkenntnis darüber, wie viel Antimaterie es im Universum
geben kann, deutlich verbessert.
Was auf der anderen Seite heißt, wenn es keine Bereiche aus Antimaterie im Universum
gibt, dann müsste es eigentlich...
Neue physikalische Wechselwirkungen geben, die diese Asymmetrie erklären zwischen
Materie und Antimaterie und heißt, dass wir also an einer anderen Stelle suchen
müssen. Wir können diesen Bereich also abschließen.
Aber wie findet man denn bitte etwas, was man noch nie gesehen hat?
Genau.
Wie baut man ein Instrument für etwas? Also nach welchem Plan kann man,
also wenn da jetzt so dieses,
Antimaterie-Kohlenstoff-Atom daherkommt, so nach langer Reise,
ein paar hundert Millionen Jahre unterwegs, trifft dann rein zufällig auf dieses
ams auf was also woran kann man denn erkennen dass es sich dabei auch um das handelt.
Ja jetzt kommt wieder unser magnet ins spiel wir messen
die elektrische ladung der teilchen indem wir diese teilchen durch unser magnetfeld
durchfliegen lassen jetzt der magnet alleine tut es nicht sondern dieses magnet
volumen wird instrumentiert das heißt wir brauchen spur detektoren die wir da
einbauen diese spur detektoren erlauben uns die flugbahn dieser dieser Teilchen zu messen.
Und zwar mit einer Genauigkeit, dass wir also sowas wie sechs bis zehn Punkte
mit einer Genauigkeit von einem tausendstel Millimeter pro Punkt bekommen.
Und damit können wir feststellen, ob die Spur rechtsrum gekrümmt ist oder linksrum
gekrümmt ist. Einmal ist es Materie, einmal ist es Antimaterie.
Und jetzt sehen wir Heliumatome, das zweithäufigste Element,
Atomkerne in der kosmischen Strahlung, messen die und sehen,
die sehen aus, wie wir das erwarten.
Und dann Dann fragen wir von diesen Teilchen, die wir gut messen können,
mit denen wir sozusagen unser Instrument kalibrieren können,
wie viele von denen gibt es mit der entgegengesetzten elektrischen Ladung?
Und dann finden wir kein einziges.
Und dann heißt das, in der kosmischen Strahlung kommt kein Antihelium vor.
Kohlenstoff konnte AMS 1 nicht. Kohlenstoff kann erst AMS 2.
Helium konnte AMS 1 schon und hat festgestellt, es gibt kein Antihelium.
So, und die spannende Frage ist immer, wie bauen Sie ein Instrument,
mit dem sie nach was Neuem suchen wollen.
Also es gibt keins oder es kam keins vorbei?
Die Antwort können wir nicht unterscheiden. Wir können nur sagen,
in der Beobachtungsdauer, die wir hatten, kam keins vorbei.
Könnte durchaus sein, dass es welche gibt, aber die sind so selten,
dass wir sie nicht sehen.
Aber wenn 96% des Universums aus Antimaterie bestehen und man interagiert üblicherweise
mit 4%, dann müsste ja eigentlich...
Moment, jetzt kommt wieder wieder das, was häufiger passiert.
Dunkle Materie, dunkle Energie, Antimaterie, das sind völlig verschiedene Sachen. Also,
diese 4% Materie, die wir im Universum haben,
Das sind Teilchen, die aus Baryonen im Wesentlichen aufgebaut sind,
die wir beobachten können.
Diese 96 Prozent dunkle Materie und dunkle Energie, da können wir ausschließen,
dass das Antimaterie ist.
Ah, noch mal was anderes.
Das hat also damit gar nichts zu tun, sondern es ist eigentlich die Frage,
wenn ich Elementarteilchen miteinander kollidieren lasse, also nach Einsteins
Formel E gleich mc² Energie in Masse umwandle, Dann habe ich ja am Anfang,
wenn ich das mache, Energie.
Energie hat keine elektrische Ladung.
Und am Ende, habe ich dann eine elektrische Ladung oder nicht?
Wenn ich unterschiedlich viel Materie und Antimaterie produziere,
habe ich eine elektrische Ladung.
Also wenn ich unterschiedlich viel Elektronen und Positronen mache,
ist die Nettoladung nachher von null verschieden.
Nur wenn ich genauso viele Elektronen wie Positronen mache, ist das,
was rauskommt, elektrisch neutral.
Alle Experimente auf der Erde zeigen uns, dass diese Symmetrie zwischen Materie
und Antimaterie weitgehend erfüllt ist.
Die kleinen Abweichungen, die wir gefunden haben, reichen bei Weitem nicht aus,
um die Asymmetrie im Universum zu erklären.
Jetzt suchen wir mit AMS nach Antimaterie. Das heißt, es könnte sein,
dass diese 4%, die die Materie ausmacht, im Universum, dass es also einen Teil
davon in Form von Antimaterie in anderen Galaxien gibt.
Und das ist die Aufgabe, was AMS versucht, diese Frage versucht AMS zu beantworten.
Und wir haben keine gefunden.
Das heißt nicht, dass es keine gibt, aber das heißt, mit der Sensitivität,
die wir hatten, konnten wir nichts sehen.
Ich versuche es wieder mal an einem Beispiel. Stellen Sie sich einen Wassertropfen
vor. Sie haben also eine Pfütze, einen Tümpel, nehmen einen Wassertropfen raus und gucken sich den an.
Und gucken und gucken und sehen nichts da drin. Und sagen, naja,
es ist Wasser, es ist halt nichts drin.
Dann kommt einer auf die Idee und sagt, ich baue ein Mikroskop.
Und guckt in den Wassertropfen. Und sieht ein ganz neues Universum.
Der sieht die Einzeller da drin, die da rumschwimmen und sie verstehen plötzlich,
wie Zellen funktionieren. Und, und, und.
Durch das Hingucken mit dem Auge haben sie nur gelernt, dass das ein Wassertropfen ist.
Durch das Hingucken mit dem Instrument, nämlich Mikroskop, was eine tausendmal
höhere Sensitivität als das Auge hat, lernen sie dann plötzlich,
was in dem Wassertropfen drin ist.
AMS 2, was wir auf die Raumstation gebracht haben, ist tausendmal empfindlicher
als alle Experimente, die wir vorher gemacht haben.
Tausendmal.
Tausendmal. Mindestens tausendmal, in einigen Bereichen auch mehr.
Was wir dabei finden, das ist die spannende Frage.
Also wenn Sie das Mikroskop gebaut haben, dann haben Sie das auch nicht darauf
ausgelegt, den Einzeller in den Wassertropfen zu finden, sondern Sie haben das
gebaut, um Strukturen aufzulösen. Das war die Anforderung.
Wir haben AMS gebaut, dass wir Elementarteilchen sehen können.
Welche wir dabei finden, das wissen wir nicht. Wir hoffen natürlich,
dass wir welche finden, die wir bisher nicht kennen und aus denen wir was Neues lernen.
So, nachdem also AMS01 so erfolgreich war, insofern als dass man bewiesen hat,
man kann es bauen, man kann es hochschieben, es geht aber nicht kaputt und es
detektiert auch tatsächlich, auch wenn nicht gerade das vorbeikam,
was man gerne gesehen hätte,
war dann die Entscheidung für ein Nachfolgeprojekt dann relativ leicht durchzusetzen?
Die Entscheidung für das Nachfolgeprojekt fiel auch noch, bevor ich an die RWTH Aachen kam.
Mein Vorgänger hat mir gesagt, es war schwierig, als ich also 2000 hier anfing.
Das war also im April 2000 und im Februar glaube ich, kam der Bescheid vom DLR,
dass wir das machen können.
Also eine Universität in Deutschland, wenigstens mit den Ressourcen,
die wir haben, kann sowas nie alleine machen.
Das muss also immer so sein. meiner meinung nach
auch zu recht dass also diese vorschläge in
einem wettbewerbsverfahren von einer wissenschaftsagentur sei das dfg sei das
dlr ausgesucht werden und dann wird gesagt also das ist das projekt was wir
verfolgen wollen das war ein riesenschritt
im vergleich zu der beteiligung über bei ms1 hatten das war so,
großenordnung also faktor zehn mehr was wir da gemacht haben.
Ich möchte, bevor ich darauf eingehe, noch einen Punkt anführen.
Also wir haben, als wir diese AMS-1-Messungen gemacht haben,
natürlich viele Teilchenflüsse gemessen in der kosmischen Strahlung und einige
Effekte gefunden, von denen man vorher gar nichts wusste.
Also zum Beispiel, wie Elementarteilchen in dem Magnetfeld der Erde gespeichert werden.
Dass die für bestimmte Sorten von Teilchen anders gespeichert werden,
als man das erwartet hat.
Also es kamen in Größenordnung zehn Publikationen raus, die sehr häufig zitiert worden sind.
Eine haben wir hier in Aachen auch komplett alleine gemacht,
relativ spät, 2003 bis 2007.
Also man sieht an der Zeitskala, wie schwierig das teilweise ist.
Die ist heute die am häufigsten zitierte Publikation von AMS überhaupt.
Und die hat Erkenntnisse über Eigenschaften von dunkler Materie geliefert.
Also nicht in dem Sinne, dass wir es gefunden haben, sondern gesagt haben,
wir messen bekannte Elementarteilchen und aus den Messungen sehen wir Hinweise
darauf, die man eventuell als Hinweise auf dunkle Materie interpretieren kann.
Also das ist ein recht komplexes Gebiet, aber es zeigt, dass die wissenschaftliche
Ausbeute von AMS 1 schon ziemlich positiv war. Also für solch einen Ingenieurflug,
eigentlich gedachten Ingenieurflug.
Dann haben wir AMS 2 genehmigt bekommen. Das war ziemlich zeitgleich mit meinem
Dienstbeginn hier an der RWTH Aachen.
Und dann hatten wir eine ganz andere Aufgabe. Wir mussten nämlich einen substanziellen
Anteil von AMS 2 hier in Aachen komplett selber entwickeln und bauen.
Und das haben wir dann in den nächsten Größenordnung fünf Jahren gemacht.
Das heißt, AMS 2 ist nicht ein einzelnes Instrument, sondern es setzt sich aus
sechs bis sieben, je nachdem wie genau man guckt, einzelnen Messinstrumenten
zusammen, die natürlich alle miteinander sprechen müssen,
Daten untereinander austauschen müssen und nachher heißt die Aufgabe,
setzt diese Einzelinformationen zusammen, man könnte sagen zu einem Gesamtbild.
Das heißt, was wir eigentlich machen, sind Fotografien von der kosmischen Strahlung.
Man kann das vielleicht mit einem Fotoapparat vergleichen, der also mit seinem
Sensor bei verschiedenen Farben misst.
Und erst wenn ich die ganz verschiedenen Farben zusammengesetzt habe,
dann weiß ich wirklich, was ich auf dem Bild habe.
Und das ist auch die Funktionsweise von AMS. Und wir haben halt den Teil von
AMS gebaut, der also sozusagen von den Teilchen als erstes durchflogen wird,
einen sogenannten Übergangsstrahlungsdetektor.
Das ist ein gasgefülltes Messinstrument, was also seine eigenen technischen
Schwierigkeiten dadurch hat, dass sie es einfach im Weltraum betreiben wollen
und Weltraum hat Vakuum.
Wenn Sie einen gasgefüllten Detektor haben, dann müssen Sie sich mal fragen,
wie dicht kann ich den bauen?
Jeder, der mal versucht hat, also nehmen Sie mal eine Wasserflasche,
die also nicht für kohlensäurehaltige Getränke ausgelegt ist,
eine Plastikflasche und füllen Sie da mal Sprudel rein und lassen das mal einen Tag stehen.
Dann werden Sie sich wundern, wie viel Kohlensäure da noch drin ist,
nämlich so gut wie gar nichts.
Und das machen sie bei einem Außendruck von einer Atmosphäre.
Jetzt machen sie das mal im Vakuum, dann geht das noch viel schneller.
Und unsere Aufgabe war, so etwas Flüchtiges wie CO2, also mit einem Strohhalm
festzuhalten, der also eine Wandstärke von weniger als einer Haardicke hat.
Gasgefüllte Röhrchen, gasgefüllte Strohhalme zu bauen und davon 5248 Stück,
sodass die dicht sind, weitgehend dicht sind, also weit das überhaupt geht.
Und die so zu bauen dass das ganze also leicht wird trotzdem groß also zwei
meter durchmesser hat dieses messinstrument 60 zentimeter höhe die fahrer.
Material muss man den das gas dann einschließen damit.
Nicht entweicht ja also dass was wir genommen haben ist also im wesentlichen
eine kapton folie da sind ganz dünne zwei mikrometer dünne aluminiumschichten zwischen,
Und daraus haben wir aus dieser Folie, haben wir also bei einer Firma in England
Strohhalme wickeln lassen.
Die Folie ist ein Zentimeter breit, wenn man die also bekommt.
Und dann hat eine Firma in England daraus Strohhalme gewickelt und dann haben
wir Größenordnung 10.000 Strohhalme, jeder Strohhalm 2,50 Meter lang,
einzeln hier getestet auf seine Gasdichtigkeit und dann 5.000 Gute ausgesucht
und damit dieses Messinstrument gebaut.
Gebaut mit der Industrie hier in dem lokalen Bereich zusammen.
Dann diese Messinstrumente, also diese einzelnen Module, die dann aus diesen
Strohhalmen bestanden, getestet, qualifiziert für die Raumfahrt,
also Schütteltests gemacht, Thermovakuumtests gemacht.
Wir haben auch hier das Klinikum, also Luisen Hospital in Aachen eingespannt,
weil die zu der Zeit also den modernsten CT-Scanner in der Region hatten.
Und wir konnten also da die Mediziner, die wir vorher hier ausgebildet haben
in der Physik, überreden, dass sie uns also nachts an ihrem Messinstrument,
also an ihren CT-Scanner herangelassen haben,
damit wir also die Geometrie aus den Röntgenbildern rekonstruieren konnten von
den Kammern, die wir gebaut haben.
Denn es ist ja nicht trivial, aus etwas, was eine Wandstärke von weniger als
einem Haardurchmesser hat, etwas zwei Meter langes zu bauen,
was also auf einen Haardurchmesser gerade ist.
Um dieses Verfahren zu entwickeln und das zu testen, haben wir also diesen CT-Scanner
am Levisen-Hospital benutzt.
Diese Gasmengen sind sehr überschaubar.
Also die Wandstärke ist nur 0,07 Millimeter.
Aber das Volumen, das ist also ein 6 Millimeter durchmessendes Röhrchen,
was zwei Meter lang ist und davon haben wir 5000.
Das gibt etwas über 200 Liter Gasvolumen, die wir da oben betreiben müssen.
Dafür gibt es ein Gasversorgungssystem, das ist am MIT in den USA entwickelt
worden. Das heißt also, wir haben einen Vorratsbehälter mitgenommen und da haben
wir also Xenon-Gas drin und CO2-Gas.
Und das wird also auf der Raumstation gemischt und damit füllen wir also die
Verluste, die wir durch die Diffusion durch diese 70 Mikrometer dicken Röhrchen
haben, die man nicht vermeiden kann.
Dann, ihre Sprudelflasche ist ja nicht undicht, wenn die Kohlensäure rausgeht.
Das diffundiert durch die Wände. Das tut es da oben natürlich auch, etwas schneller noch.
Und das heißt, wir müssen so einmal im Monat Gas nachfüllen,
damit das also stabile Bedingungen gibt für die Messungen, die wir machen wollen.
Was ist denn jetzt, ist das jetzt schon die Basis des Funktionsprinzips?
Also, das ist die erste Schicht, auf die die Teilchen auftreffen,
sind diese Röhrchen mit diesem Xenon-Gasgemisch.
Warum? Also warum?
Warum machen wir das?
Warum ist das?
Ich hatte versucht zu erklären, dass also der Magnet und der Spurdetektor ausreichen,
um den Impuls und die Ladung zu messen.
Genau, weil man die Richtung nachweisen kann. Genau, weil man die Flugbahn rekonstruiert
und dann weiß man aus der Krümmung, also rechts rum gekrümmt oder links rum
die elektrische Ladung.
Und je hochenergetischer das Teilchen ist, desto schneller fliegt es durch das
Magnetfeld durch und desto weniger kann es sich also krümmen.
Ja, also das heißt, die Stärke der Krümmung ist ein Maß für die Energie der Teilchen.
So funktioniert das ja auch beim LHC letztlich.
So funktioniert das beim LHC, so funktioniert das bei allen Teilchenphysikexperimenten
und so hat auch früher ihr Fernseher funktioniert.
Also ihr Röhrenfernseher, da war eine Elektronenkanone drin und ein Magnet und
die Elektronen wurden abgelenkt und damit wurde zeilenweise ihr Bild aufgebaut.
So, jetzt drehen wir das nur um. Also wir erzeugen die Elektronen nicht selber,
sondern die kommen von außen.
Wir lassen das Magnetfeld konstant und gucken uns an, wo fliegen die lang.
Und dann wissen wir, welche Energie die haben und welche elektrische Ladung,
also positiv oder negativ.
Aber da muss man ja auch schon eine gewisse Erwartungshaltung haben,
was für eine maximale Energie überhaupt auf einen einschlägt.
Ich meine, bei dieser Dimensionierung des Magneten muss man ja dann auch schon
so eine gewisse Erwartung haben, nicht, dass die dann alle so schnell kommen,
dass man nur noch gerade Linien sieht. Richtig.
Das heißt also, solch ein Messinstrument hat eine gewisse Auflösung.
Genauso wie unser Mikroskop. Je besser die Linse, desto besser ist die Auflösung.
Bei AMS wird das limitiert durch die Genauigkeit, mit der ich die einzelnen
Spurpunkte messen kann.
Das geht halt auf Mikrometer genau und nicht auf Nanometer. Also das limitiert
die Genauigkeit, mit der ich die Flugbahn kenne. Und dann kann man den Magneten
nicht beliebig stark bauen.
Also je stärker der Magnet, desto stärker werden die Teilchen abgelenkt.
Aber die Technologie hat da natürliche Begrenzungen. Das heißt,
Wir können bis zu Energien, und jetzt ist die Frage, wie versteht man das,
bis zu 2 TeV, können wir Informationen aus dieser Krümmung und aus dieser Flugbahn
extrahieren, was das für Teilchen waren, welche Energie die hatten.
Was heißt Teraelektronenvolt?
TEV sind Teraelektronenvolt. Was ist ein Elektronenvolt?
Das ist die kinetische Energie, die ein Teilchen gewinnt, wenn es ein elektrisches
Potenzial von einem Volt durchläuft.
Sie machen einen Plattenkondensator, eine Spannung von einem Volt dazwischen.
Welche Energie gewinnt das Teilchen, wenn es da durchläuft?
Das gewinnt eine Energie von einem Elektronenvolt. Und wir können bis 2 TEV
Elektronenvolt Aussagen treffen, was das für Teilchen waren.
Das klingt aber schon ganz schön energetisch.
Das ist schon ganz schön energetisch. Da gibt es auch nur noch wenig Teilchen,
die mit so hohen Energien kommen. Aber es gibt Teilchen mit viel höheren Energien.
Die kommen.
Das heißt, und es könnte durchaus sein, dass die Interessanten die sind,
die noch viel höher energetischer sind und wir können das nicht rauskriegen.
Da haben wir aber keine Wahl.
Irgendwas muss man ja machen.
Wie wenn Sie das Mikroskop bauen. Sie können die Linsen nur nehmen,
die Sie haben. Vom Elektronenmikroskop wissen Sie noch nichts.
Also mehr wäre jetzt auch technisch gar nicht möglich gewesen oder man hat sich
einfach nur entschlossen, diesen Bereich zu nehmen in der Erwartung,
dass man da schon genug Erkenntnisse sammeln kann?
Also wir sind mit den Technologien über das hinausgegangen, was man konnte,
als das vorgeschlagen worden ist.
Wir haben in vielen Fällen Neuland da betreten und man kann immer sagen,
ich hätte gerne noch eine bessere Auflösung.
Aber da muss man Gründe für haben und man muss das auch technisch können.
Wissenschaftlich, als das Experiment geplant war, sind wir davon ausgegangen,
dass in dem Energiebereich, den wir abdenken können, interessante Sachen passieren.
Ob das wirklich so ist, da halte ich mich gerne mit Ihnen.
Was wir machen können als Wissenschaftler, ist ein Instrument bauen,
was eine tolle Auflösung hat und toll funktioniert. Das können wir beeinflussen.
Was wir nicht beeinflussen können, ist, was die Natur macht.
Also irgendjemand hat mal festgelegt, wie dieses Universum aussieht, wie das funktioniert.
Auf diese Entscheidungen haben wir keinen Einfluss. Wir kennen sie auch nicht.
Also wir können nur aus unseren Beobachtungen darauf schließen, was da passiert ist.
Und wenn sie sich den Wassertropfen, also wenn sie destilliertes Wasser genommen
hätten unter ihrem Mikroskop, hätten sie nichts gesehen und gesagt, Wasser ist langweilig.
Ja gut, aber ich schätze mal bei AMS01 hat man ja, hat man da auch schon die
Energie selbst messen können?
AMS hat genauso funktioniert, allerdings hat das eine Auflösung,
die war um einen Faktor 40 schlechter.
Das heißt, wir konnten nicht bis 2 TeV das Ganze messen, sondern die Energieverteilung,
die wir aufgezeichnet haben, hören so bei 50 GeV etwa auf.
Ja, und es gab viele Komponenten, also abgesehen von der Energie und der Ladung
des Teilchens wollen sie ja noch was mehr wissen.
Also der eigentliche Angriffspunkt war ja, warum macht ihr diese Röhrchen da oben drauf?
Ein Teilchen hat zusätzlich noch eine Masse. Und das heißt, was wir wissen wollen,
ist die elektrische Ladung, die Energie und die Masse.
Dann wissen wir alles über das Teilchen, was uns interessiert im Moment.
Und die Masse messen ist sehr schwierig, denn was wir eigentlich bei dieser
Ablenkung in dem Magnetfeld messen, ist der Impuls und der Impuls ist Masse mal Geschwindigkeit.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt an die Masse will, muss ich irgendwie die Geschwindigkeit messen.
Der Nachteil von diesen hochenergetischen Teilchen, also bei 100,
also bei GEV-Energien, also 10 hoch 12 Elektronenvolt-Energien,
die sind alle so schnell, die bewegen sich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Es gibt eine Höchstgeschwindigkeit und das ist die Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Und das heißt, diese Abweichung von der Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist so klein,
dass Sie das nicht messen können.
Sie sind praktisch mit konstanter Geschwindigkeit.
Also müssen Sie sich andere Effekte überlegen, wie Sie Geschwindigkeit kriegen.
Und dieser Übergangsstrahlungsdetektor, der aus diesen Röhrchen besteht und
oben auf AMS drauf sitzt, dessen Aufgabe ist es, die Masse von Teilchen zu messen
über einen quantenmechanischen Effekt.
Und dieser Effekt nennt sich Übergangsstrahlung, das ist auch nicht weiter schwierig zu verstehen.
Wenn Sie also ein Teilchen haben, was also Übergänge passiert,
das können zum Beispiel dünne Folien sein, die Sie hintereinander stapeln,
dann muss dieses Teilchen an jedem dieser Übergänge ein Photon abstrahlen.
Damit die, also physikalisch gesprochen, damit die Wellenfunktion stetig und
differenzierbar einen Übergang hat bei dem Durchgang durch die verschiedenen
Medien mit einer verschiedenen Dielektrizitätskonstante.
Also einfach damit die elektromagnetische Welle funktioniert, die dazu gehört.
Und diese Übergangsstrahlung messen wir zusätzlich. Und damit können wir unterscheiden
zwischen leichten Teilchen und schweren Teilchen.
Denn die Energie dieser Übergangsstrahlung hängt davon ab, ab welches Verhältnis
zwischen Energie und Masse dieses Teilchens besteht.
Und diesen Effekt benutzen wir, um zwischen leichten Teilchen und schweren Teilchen zu unterscheiden.
Und das passiert am Eingang von AMS. Und dann gibt es im unteren Teil noch andere
Komponenten, die also auch versuchen, teilweise direkt die Geschwindigkeit zu messen.
Das funktioniert bei kleinen Energien und dann gibt es unten noch ein sogenanntes
Kalorimeter und das absorbiert Teilchen zum ersten Mal.
Also bis dahin versuchen wir nicht destruktiv zu messen, um die Teilchen nicht
zu beeinflussen. Aber ganz unten absorbieren wir die Elementarteilchen und messen ihre Energie.
Und dann wissen wir eigentlich ziemlich viel über dieses Teilchen.
Wie absorbiert man die denn, wenn die da mit so Tera-Elektronen-Volt-Power da ankommen?
Also viele Teilchen können wir nicht absorbieren, also die Protonen zum Beispiel,
der Wasserstoffkern am häufigsten im Universum, den können wir nicht absorbieren.
Aber das ist auch schon eine Messung. Also wenn Sie da nur einen kleinen Energieeintrag
messen, dann wissen Sie, das war ein Proton, das ist nämlich durchgeflogen.
Ich sehe in allen Lagen von diesem Instrument gleich viel Energie deponiert.
Wenn da allerdings ein Elektron oder ein Positron ankommt oder ein Photon ankommt,
dann fängt das einen anderen physikalischen Prozess an und deponiert in den
Bleilagen seine Energie.
Zum Glück für uns.
Das ist einfach nur Blei im Wesentlichen?
Ja, also Blei alleine wird es ja wieder nicht tun, weil wenn Sie da nur einen
Absorber hinstellen, dann wissen Sie nicht, was passiert.
Also Sie müssen diesen Absorber instrumentieren. Also das heißt,
Sie müssen wieder Messinstrumente einbauen, die Ihnen sagen,
wie viel Energie ist denn da deponiert worden. Und das messen wir.
Und die Elektronen und Positronen und Photonen deponieren ihre Energie in dem
Kalorimeter und die Protonen nicht.
Und damit können wir für diese Elementarteilchen die Energie messen und auch
identifizieren, dass es dieses Teilchen war.
Das heißt, wir wissen dann, was die Masse ist, weil nur die das tun. tun.
Es ist wie so ein Puzzle. Da fliegt ein Teilchen durch und das macht in dem
einen Detektor das, in dem nächsten Detektor das, in dem nächsten Detektor das.
Und dann schauen wir uns das Muster an und sagen, mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit
in dem ersten Detektor ist das das, in dem zweiten Detektor ist das,
in dem dritten Detektor ist das.
Und dann suchen wir die Hypothese, die die Wahrscheinlichkeiten maximiert und
sagen, höchstwahrscheinlich war das das und,
Und die Kunst ist, das so zu machen, dass sie in möglichst vielen Fällen eine
eindeutige Aussage treffen können.
Und so haben wir dieses Instrument entwickelt und dann haben wir das natürlich
nicht nur gebaut, sondern wir haben das in einem Teststrahl am CERN mit bekannten
Teilchen kalibriert, um zu sehen, dass das genau so funktioniert, wie wir das erwarten.
Und die Eigenschaften also überprüft, bevor wir das auf die Raumstation gebracht haben.
Sammelt, also überträgt den AMS diese ganzen Messdaten in Echtzeit,
also empfängt man jetzt bereits den Datenstrom?
Ja, also das ist so, das ist einer der Gründe warum wir auf der Raumstation
sind also wir brauchen sehr viel Strom,
die Raumstation hat sehr viel Strom, also über die großen Solarpaneele und der
zweite Grund ist, wir brauchen sehr viel Bandbreite um diese Daten auf die Erde zu übertragen,
und die werden in Echtzeit übertragen, das
ist nicht trivial wir haben also in am
es selber so was wie 650 computer eingebaut
die in echtzeit diese daten komprimieren
wenn wir das alles richtig gemacht haben so komprimieren dass wir dabei keine
physikalischen informationen die für uns wichtig sind verliert und das was übrig
bleibt wird also übertragen über eine funk strecke über satelliten in die usa
und Und von da aus an das CERN-Forschungszentrum in Genf.
Und da sitzt unser Payload Operation und Control Center.
Und von da aus betreiben wir das Experiment. Und da ist auch das Science Operation
Center. Und da werden die Daten also analysiert.
Und dann werden sie an alle Forschungsinstitute, die dann beteiligt sind, verteilt.
Werden die Rohdaten auch gespeichert? Ja. Also wenn das dann mal zurückkommt,
dann hat man das auch noch.
Ah, Moment. Also die sozusagen unprozessierten Unkompromisse.
Das ist immer die spannende Frage, wie seid ihr sicher, dass ihr also nichts verliert.
Es gibt verschiedene Ebenen, auf denen diese Kompressionsalgorithmen passieren.
Und wir übertragen auf die Erde sowohl unkomprimierte als auch komprimierte Daten.
Von den unkomprimierten Daten aber nur einen ganz kleinen Bruchteil,
um das Datenvolumen klein zu halten. Und wir sind damit in der Lage,
die Kompressionsalgorithmen, die wir benutzen, zu optimieren und zu überprüfen.
Also ob wir damit physikalische Informationen verlieren.
Aber für die meisten Ereignisse werden die unkomprimierten Daten weggeschmissen.
Aber für einen Bruchteil, für einen kleinen Bruchteil gucken wir uns die an,
um sicher zu sein, dass wir nichts übersehen.
Das heißt quasi so ein Verifikationskanal nochmal zusätzlich, um sicher zu sein und,
das Ganze ist ja jetzt Mai 2011 gestartet, womit ist es gestartet?
War der letzte Flug von der Endeavour vom Kennedy Space Center gestartet das war also,
Ja, also eine etwas schwierige Operation, weil das Space Shuttle dann an der
Raumstation angedockt ist, dann muss das mit dem Roboterarm aus der Endeavor,
also die Endeavor selber hat einen eigenen Roboterarm, rausgenommen werden,
dann an den kanadischen Roboterarm an der Raumstation übergeben werden,
dann an die richtige Stelle bewegt werden und da muss man sich vorstellen,
da ist eine Klammer, die schnappt dann ein und dann gibt es also ein elektrisches
Kabel, was also den Power zur Verfügung stellt und ein optisches Kabel,
was die Daten da rausholt. Und das ist es.
Und die sind eingerastet und wir haben dann also….
Also die ganze Installation wurde komplett robotisch gemacht, ohne Außeneinsatz der….
Ohne Außeneinsatz der Astronauten. Die standen also an den Joysticks und haben
also die Roboterarme bedient.
Und vier Stunden nach der Installation haben wir also mit der Datennahme angefangen.
Die läuft seitdem durch. Wir haben inzwischen sowas wie 16 Milliarden Teilchen
in der kosmischen Strahlung aufgezeichnet. aufgezeichnet, auf die Erde gefunkt.
Also das Instrument ist rund um die Uhr in Betrieb.
Wir sehen solche Sachen wie zum Beispiel Flares auf der Sonne.
Jetzt im Januar war also extrem hochenergetisch eine Eruption auf der Sonne.
Und wir sehen das in den Elementarteilchenflüssen hier, die wir beobachten.
Das ist eine der interessanten Beobachtungen für die Raumfahrtagenturen.
Ziel von AMS ist solch einen kompletten Sonnenzyklus. Also die Aktivität der
Sonne variiert über elf Jahre.
Wenn Sie einen Astronauten zum Mars bringen wollen, dann müssen Sie über einen
solchen Elfjahreszyklus verstehen,
welche geladenen Teilchen kommen von der Sonne, welche Wirkungen haben die auf
das Erbgut, also müssen Sie wissen, welche Energie die haben und welche Teilchen das sind.
Und eine der Aufgaben von AMS, also sozusagen die Brot- und Butterphysik, ist,
diese Teilchenflüsse zu messen und damit ein Modell zu liefern,
um eine Abschirmung überhaupt auslegen
zu können, mit der man also einen Astronaut zum Mars bringen kann.
Erst mal wissen, was da drin ist im Regen.
Im Moment weiß man sehr wenig davon. Also wenn Sie das heute auslegen würden,
dann kommen Sie so auf Massenabschätzungen in der Größenordnung von 1000 Tonnen
für die Abschirmung, was nichts ist, was Sie also irgendwie zum Mars bringen könnten.
Allerdings, was Sie noch mehr beunruhigen muss, ist, dass die Abschirmung einen
Unsicherheitsfaktor von 5 hat.
Das heißt, wenn Sie auf die sichere Seite gehen wollten, müssten Sie 5000 Tonnen Abschirmung bauen.
Das will keiner zum Mars fliegen. Also die Aufgabe ist, diesen Faktor 5 klein zu kriegen.
Und dann gibt es auch Ideen dazu, wie man von diesen 1000 Tonnen auf 20 Tonnen
runterkommt, indem man diese Abschirmung nicht passiv macht,
also aus Aluminium, sondern indem man das mit Magnetfeldern macht,
wie die Erde das auch macht und damit dann Leute zum Mars bringen kann.
Aber das ist ja schon ein interessanter Dual Use an der Stelle,
dass man ja hier eigentlich das Experiment aufgebaut hat, um Grundlagenforschung,
also vor allem Grundlagenforschung zu machen,
dass man aber im Prinzip jetzt auch schon konkrete Informationen gewinnt,
die jetzt auch für zukünftige Missionen einen Wert haben.
Ja, also es gibt bei solchen komplexen Forschungsprojekten immer ganz verschiedene Aspekte.
Das eine ist, die Raumfahrtagenturen, um es vorsichtig zu sagen,
also wie das Universum zustande gekommen ist, ist nicht ihr primäres Forschungsinteresse.
Ja.
Aber bemannte Raumfahrt im Sonnensystem zu ermöglichen, gehört zu ihren primären Aufgaben.
Wenn man das hinkriegen will, muss man das alles verstanden haben.
Und AMS bietet sozusagen die Möglichkeit, zum ersten Mal über längere Zeit,
weil es auf der Raumstation ist und nicht an einem Ballon hängt in den oberen
Schichten der Erdatmosphäre oder ein kurz fliegender Satellit ist,
sondern Messdauern von 20 Jahren erreichen soll,
das systematisch zu untersuchen.
Dieser Dual Use Aspect, bei dem ersten Vorschlag von AMS 2 war der noch mehr
dabei, da war nämlich ein supraleitender Magnet vorgeschlagen worden,
also statt dem Permanentmagneten bei AMS 1 ein supraleitender Magnet.
Der also gekühlt werden müsste dann?
Der müsste mit suprafluidem Helium auf unter zwei Kelvin gekühlt werden,
damit er da oben funktioniert.
Solch ein Magnet wäre in der Lage, eine magnetische Abschirmung für ein Raumfahrzeug
zu machen und damit würde er nur 20 Tonnen wiegen und damit könnten sie das
tatsächlich zum Mars fliegen, ohne dass sie sich über Strahlenschäden Gedanken machen müssen.
Das war, dass man sozusagen gar nicht da so eine dicke Bleiwand drauf macht,
sondern einfach so ein fettes Magnetfeld erzeugt quasi.
Zehn Tesla, Magnetfeld mit einem supraleitenden Magneten hätte ausgereicht.
Dafür müssten sie aber, bevor sie sich sowas trauen, nachweisen,
dass man einen supraleitenden Magneten im Weltraum betreiben kann.
Das hat noch keiner geschafft. Das will man schon lange.
Und am Ende muss man sagen, AMS hat es auch nicht geschafft oder nicht gemacht
am Ende, weil wir kurz vor dem Flug entschieden haben, dass wir also auf den
Permanentmagneten zurückgehen.
Das Problem mit diesen Magneten ist,
Super fluides Helium ist also im Weltraum technisch extrem schwierig,
weil das keine Oberflächenspannung mehr hat.
Das heißt, Sie können das nicht pumpen. Sie wissen nicht, wo das ist.
Das ist einfach verteilt an den Oberflächen, sitzt das irgendwo.
Und wenn Sie eine Pumpe da hinsetzen, dann pumpt das alles Mögliche,
aber im Wesentlichen kein Helium, weil das Helium irgendwo anders ist.
Also Sie fangen mit einem vollen Tank an, da ist natürlich Helium drin,
da können Sie pumpen, wo Sie wollen.
Aber wenn Sie ein bisschen was davon raus haben, dann sitzt das Helium irgendwo,
aber nicht da, wo Ihre Pumpe.
Und man nuckelt die ganze Zeit am Nichts.
Man nuckelt am Nix. Also man muss sich dazu einige technische Lösungen einfallen lassen.
Dieses superfluide Helium ist also physikalisch extrem interessant.
Man kann das über Temperaturunterschiede von einem Ort in den anderen bewegen,
aber diese Temperaturunterschiede, die sie brauchen, sind tausendstel Grad.
Und so rauspumpen, also nicht raussaugen, sondern so rausdrücken?
Ja, also mit so einem Kolben oder sowas. Dieses Helium geht durch jeden Spalt.
Also Sie können nichts da irgendwie, das interessiert das gar nicht.
Das fließt da einfach dran vorbei.
Egal wie gut Sie das machen, das können Sie völlig vergessen.
Das Problem war mit diesem supraleitenden Magneten, dass wir den also fertig gebaut hatten 2010.
Und Der ist schon gebaut worden.
Der war komplett fertig. Und da muss man jetzt wieder verstehen,
wie ist AMS eigentlich genehmigt worden?
AMS ist genehmigt worden für einen Flug auf der Raumstation von drei Jahren.
Nach drei Jahren sollte es mit dem Space Shuttle wieder nach unten gebracht werden, auf die Erde.
Und wie wir alle wissen, durch die Abstürze der Space Shuttle hat sich also
das Raumfahrtprogramm signifikant verändert.
AMS ist lange verzögert worden.
Und als wir soweit waren, dass wir diesen supraleitenden Magneten also in bei
der S-TEC in Nordwijk getestet haben in einer Thermowakuumkammer,
das war das erste Mal, dass wir ihn testen konnten.
Also wir brauchen eine sehr große Testeinrichtung, um überhaupt zu verstehen,
wie das funktioniert im Vakuum.
Da kam dabei raus, der sollte also eine Lebensdauer von 36 Monate haben,
er hatte aber nur eine von 30.
Also es war nicht so, dass der nicht funktionierte und diese Unsicherheit auf
unsere Messungen war Größenordnung vier Monate.
Er war nicht weit von der Spezifikation weg. Eigentlich war er sehr nah dran
und mit ein bisschen Optimismus hätten wir auch gesagt, also das versuchen wir.
Aber genau zu dem Zeitpunkt, als wir diese Messungen gemacht haben bei der S-TEC
in Nordwijk, gab es eine Tagung der Raumfahrtagenturen in Tokio und da haben
sich die Chefs der Raumfahrtagenturen darauf geeinigt, die Lebensdauer der ISS zu verlängern.
Und Shuttle-Flüge, um AMS wieder runterzubringen, gab es auch nicht mehr.
Und das heißt, die Frage war, wollen wir AMS da hochbringen und nach 30 Monaten
eventuell ist Feierabend?
Oder bauen wir AMS um auf einen Permanentmagneten und können damit dann 20 Jahre lang messen?
Und dann haben wir gesagt, wir bauen um auf den Permanentmagneten.
Das ist sicherer, das erlaubt uns 20 Jahre Messzeit, wir können viel tollere Physik machen.
Haben AMS, also von der S-TEC wieder zurück zum CERN gebracht und haben hier
in Aachen an der RWTH den Permanentmagneten von AMS 1 so umgebaut,
dass er in AMS 2 reinpasst.
Also es ist tatsächlich derselbe Magnet?
Es ist derselbe, nicht der gleiche, sondern es ist wirklich derselbe Magnet
wie in dem ersten Space Shuttle Discovery geflogen.
Und wir haben hier innerhalb von drei Monaten es hingekriegt,
den so umzubauen, dass er er von außen genauso aussieht wie der supraleitende Magnet.
Und zwar nicht, damit er von außen so aussieht, sondern wenn Sie ein fertiges
komplexes Instrument haben, dann können Sie nicht das Herzstück davon rausnehmen
und durch was anderes ersetzen, was anders aussieht, wenn Sie innerhalb von
sechs Monaten den Flug hinkriegen wollen.
Und sowohl NASA als auch DLR haben diese Entscheidung unterstützt.
Das ist schon echt hardcore.
Also so ein halbes Jahr bevor das Ding startet, Operation am Herzen sozusagen.
Ja, am offenen Herzen und wir waren aber im August dann soweit,
dass wir das fertige Instrument am CERN testen konnten und waren im September
am Kennedy Space Center. Der Start sollte im Oktober stattfinden.
Wie immer bei Raumfahrtprogrammen, der hat sich dann verzögert,
weil die Discovery vorher nicht vom Boden wegkam.
Die hatte also Probleme mit dem Wasserstofftank. Deshalb ist unser Start erst
im Mai dann passiert, aber die Vorgabe von der NASA war, entweder ihr seid im
September da oder ihr könnt es vergessen. Ja.
Hat geklappt.
Heißt keine Consumables mehr, also kein Verbrauchsmaterial, was unsere Lebensdauer beschränkt.
Das heißt, wir sehen ganz entspannt den Entscheidungen entgegen,
wie lange es die ISS gibt.
Es wird auf jeden Fall noch für die nächsten zwei Jahre sein.
Also ich habe nichts davon gehört.
Dass die ISS zugemacht wird.
Und alles, was länger ist, ist ein Plus für uns. Und wir können tolle Sachen da beobachten.
Denn bei den Sachen, die wir beobachten, ist ja nicht klar,
dass nicht ein seltenes Ereignis wie zum Beispiel eine Supernova-Explosion in
unserer Galaxie uns tolle physikalische Ergebnisse liefert, die wir eigentlich
nicht vorhersagen können, weil nur eine Supernova in unserer Galaxie alle 30 Jahre passiert.
Wenn wir aber 20 Jahre da oben sind, dann haben wir eine ziemlich gute Chance,
dass wir bei einer, die in der Nachbarschaft ist, messen können.
Und es müsste aber eine sehr nahe sein.
Also wenn ich die Messergebnisse kennen würde, dann würde ich Ihnen sagen, wie nah die sein muss.
Ja, aber umso näher.
Umso besser.
Das dient als Beispiel dafür, dass, wenn Sie an dem Beschleuniger sind,
dann machen Sie immer die gleichen Kollisionen. Ja.
Und dann geht es nur darum, möglichst viele davon aufzuzeichnen.
Wenn Sie da im Weltraum sind, dann gibt es Ereignisse, singuläre Ereignisse,
die dazu führen können, dass Sie Sachen sehen, die Sie ein Jahr vorher nicht
sehen können und ein Jahr später auch nicht sehen können.
Das heißt, es ist nicht so einfach zu beantworten, wie lange will man denn da
oben eigentlich messen.
Ja, es ist Regen in der Wüste. ist.
Wegen in der Wüste, ich finde ein anderes Beispiel schöner.
Es gab dieses Super-Kamiokande-Experiment in Japan, dessen eigentliche Aufgabe
war, die Lebensdauer von den Protonen zu messen.
Und was die gefunden haben zwischendurch, sind Neutrinos von einer Supernova-Explosion,
weil halt 1987 gerade eine Supernova in unserer Galaxie explodiert ist.
Und die haben die Ankunftszeiten von den Neutrinos gemessen und damit rausgekriegt,
dass die also sich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen.
Das war Das war das tollste Resultat von denen. Das können sie nicht vorhersagen,
das können sie nicht planen.
Sie können nur in ihrem Proposal schreiben, wenn sowas passiert,
dann können wir das auch.
Was ich eigentlich sagen will, das Spannendste an AMS ist ja nicht das,
was wir auf unserer Liste stehen haben.
Wir haben eine lange Liste von Forschungsthemen. Von Strahlungsmessungen für
die bemannte Raumfahrt über dunkle Materie, über neue Materieformen,
die wir in Neutronensternen erwarten,
bis zur Propagation von geladenen Teilchen im galaktischen Magnetfeld,
was wir alles untersuchen wollen.
Darauf haben wir das Instrument optimiert. Aber wenn wir das alles finden,
da haben wir ein tolles wissenschaftliches Programm, aber der Durchbruch,
die Neuheit, das, was die Welt verändert, war nicht dabei.
Nur wenn wir was finden, was wir nicht auf unserer Liste haben,
was wir nicht erwartet haben, dann schaffen wir ja wirklich neues Wissen.
Das ist ein Glücksspiel. Also ich bin, wenn Sie mich jetzt fragen,
ja und was ist das? Und werdet ihr das finden?
Naja, das ist mir schon klar. Das ist ein Mysterium.
Das ist das Spannende an Wissenschaft. Wir machen ein Experiment,
wo noch nie einer ein Experiment gemacht hat mit dieser Genauigkeit.
Aber was konnte denn schon abgehakt werden? Also seit einem Jahr werden Daten geliefert.
Man sieht wahrscheinlich den Daten dann relativ schnell schon mal so einen gewissen
Grundwert an. Aber natürlich ist eine wissenschaftliche Auswertung auch dessen ein Trägerprozess.
Gibt es denn schon irgendetwas, was schon hat abgehakt werden können?
Zeichnet sich ab, dass für einen bestimmten Bereich das sehr gut oder vielleicht
auch gar nicht funktioniert?
Ja, also jetzt muss man sich das, es hört sich ein bisschen überheblich an,
aber es ist ein bisschen schwieriger als Fernseher einschalten.
Also ich versuche das mal wieder mit einer Analogie zu machen.
Stellen Sie sich vor, Sie sind vor 20 Jahren und Sie haben einen Fernseher mit
einer Zimmerantenne in Ihrem Wohnwagen und Sie wollen ein gutes Bild kriegen.
Dann richten Sie die Zimmerantenne aus, dann haben Sie ein gutes Bild.
Jetzt machen wir es ein bisschen schwieriger, ich lasse Ihren Wohnwagen fahren.
Dann sind Sie die ganze Zeit da dran und drehen an Ihrer Antenne,
um das Bild stabil zu halten.
Wir haben nicht einen Fernseher, wir haben 300.000. Und wir versuchen,
um in dem Bild zu bleiben, 300.000 Antennen auszurichten, aber unser Wohnwagen
ist ein bisschen schneller als ihrer.
Wir fliegen nämlich in 90 Minuten einmal um die Erde rum.
Das heißt, unsere Randbedingungen, alles, was drumherum ist,
ändert sich kontinuierlich.
Die Sonneneinstrahlung ändert sich, damit ändern sich die Temperaturen.
Die Raumstation ist nicht primär dafür da, als Plattform für AMS zu dienen,
Sondern die ist für ein eigenes wissenschaftliches Programm zuständig.
Das heißt, da kommen Sojus-Kapseln an, da kommen Space Shuttle an,
die Raumstation wird gedreht, Solarpaneele sind in unserer Akzeptanz.
Mal haben wir Schatten, mal haben wir Sonne.
Die NASA unterstützt uns nach allen Möglichkeiten Also um Beispiel zu sagen,
es gibt da Radiatoren, um die Wärme der Raumstation abzustrahlen,
Wenn es uns zu kalt wird, dann dreht die NASA diese Radiatoren so,
dass die uns heizen Und zwar gezielt, also punktuell heizen,
wenn es an einigen Punkten zu kalt wird,
Dieser Betrieb von AMS auf der Raumstation selber ist eine Herausforderung an
sich Wir haben also in der Größenordnung zwölf Leute, 24 Stunden,
sieben Tage die Woche, auf Schicht, die dieses Instrument überwachen.
Und zwar nur überwachen, dass das funktioniert, also sich noch überhaupt nicht
die Daten angeguckt haben.
Ja.
Wir haben dann ein wesentlich größeres Team, was also die Daten,
die da runterkommen, analysiert und versucht zu verstehen, ob diese ganzen Effekte,
die also zu Veränderungen führen können, ob wir die korrigieren können.
Das nennt man Kalibration in der Physik.
Das heißt, wir wollen sicherstellen, dass wenn wir was Neues finden,
das nichts damit zu tun hat, dass vielleicht ein Solarpanel irgendwie komisch
stand und wir da Sekundärteilchen herbekommen.
Ja.
Und das, was für uns, Was ist Ihre Bilanz nach einem Jahr?
Ich war bei diesem Start am Kennedy Space Center.
Von diesen über sieben Tonnen, fast die Hälfte davon war von Strukturen gehalten,
die ich zu verantworten habe, also die an der RWTH gebaut oder in Auftrag gegeben worden waren.
Da waren sieben Leute, die haben dem ihr Leben anvertraut, dass wir hier keinen Fehler gemacht haben.
Als ich das erste Foto gesehen habe aus der Ladebucht, wo dieses Instrument
intakt war, keine Metallstreben irgendwie rausstanden, nicht auseinandergefallen.
Das war für mich die größte Erleichterung. Das ist eine enorme Verantwortung
gewesen für solch ein Uni-Institut.
Das nächste, als wir auf der Raumstation ankamen und das angestellt haben,
Unsere Röhrchen aus dieser 70 Mikrometer dicken Folie, die sind mittlerweile über 20 Jahre alt.
Die sind zusammengeklebt.
20 Jahre alt?
Über 20 Jahre. Das Rohmaterial wurde in den 90er Jahren hergestellt.
Dass das nach solch einem Shuttle-Start auf der Raumstation im Vakuum alle 5248
Kanäle funktionieren. Wir haben nicht einen einzelnen verloren.
Da sind 30 Mikrometer dicke vergoldete Wolframdrähte in diesen Röhrchen gespannt,
die eigentlich die elektrischen Signale dann rausholen. Die sind zwei Meter lang.
Kein einziger von denen ist gerissen. Das funktioniert 100 Prozent.
Und diese Geschichte, was ich jetzt an dem Beispiel von diesem Übergangsstrahlungsdetektor
erzähle, den wir gebaut haben, und man merkt vielleicht, dass ich ein bisschen
zufrieden oder stolz darauf bin, dass das alles funktioniert hat,
das gilt für die anderen Gruppen genauso.
Wir sehen oder wir sind mittlerweile in der Lage zu sagen, dass dieses Instrument
genau so funktioniert, wie wir es konzipiert haben.
Und das heißt natürlich auch, der Betrieb ist wesentlich schwieriger,
als wenn das nicht so gut funktionieren würde.
Also wenn Sie etwas bauen, was unpräzise ist, dann müssen Sie sich nicht viel
Mühe geben, um damit was zu machen.
Also Sie wollen die Länge eines Tisches messen und Sie haben einen Maßstab,
der recht ungenau ist, dann kommt es nicht darauf an, wie gut Sie den anlegen.
Aber wenn Sie eine Mikrometerschraube haben, dann müssen Sie sich schon Gedanken
darüber machen, bei welcher Temperatur habe ich denn gemessen.
Dieses Instrument funktioniert hervorragend. Das ist von allen Daten,
die wir sehen. Es funktioniert hervorragend.
Aber das heißt, dass wir jede Kleinigkeit verstehen müssen, um sicher zu sein,
mit der Genauigkeit, mit der wir nachher gucken, um wieder das Mikroskop zu
nehmen, die Linse war nicht krumm, sondern da war wirklich was.
Und damit sind wir gegenwärtig beschäftigt. Das machen wir jetzt seit einem
Jahr und das wird immer besser.
Also wir nähern uns einem Zustand, wo wir die ganzen Computerprogramme,
also am Ende passiert das natürlich mit Computerprogrammen, Sie werten 20 Milliarden Ereignisse,
die werten sie nicht von Hand aus,
sondern sie müssen Computeralgorithmen entwickeln und die müssen alle Eventualitäten kennen,
die bis dahin aufgetreten sind, um damit fertig zu werden.
Und was wir machen, ist diese Software zu entwickeln, zu testen,
ans Laufen zu kriegen, um stabile wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse zu produzieren.
Und wir nähern uns einem Zustand, dass wir das können und fangen jetzt an,
uns mit den physikalischen Fragestellungen, also unserem eigentlichen Forschungsprogramm,
denn Instrumentverstehen ist ja nicht das Forschungsprogramm,
das ist Mittel zum Zweck.
Wir fangen jetzt an mit unserem eigentlichen Forschungsprogramm uns zu beschäftigen
und das Ziel ist, dass wir Ende 2012, Anfang 2013 soweit sind,
die ersten wissenschaftlichen Ergebnisse zu publizieren.
Also nicht technische Ergebnisse, irgendwas funktioniert so gut,
sondern die ersten wissenschaftlichen Ergebnisse zu produzieren.
Und wir sehen an Beispielen schon, dass das hervorragend funktioniert.
Und ein Beispiel möchte ich nennen, also wir wissen, dass das Antiteilchen zum
Elektron dass das das Positron ist.
Wir haben in den AMS1-Daten schon gesehen, dass es mehr Positronen in der kosmischen
Höhenstrahlung gibt, als wir erwarten.
Und wir können jetzt mit AMS2 das zu viel höheren Energien messen,
mit viel mehr Statistik.
Und die höchstenergetischen Positronen, also Antiteilchen zum Elektronen,
die je in der kosmischen Höhenstrahlung nachgewiesen worden sind,
die sind mit AMS2 jetzt aufgezeichnet worden.
Wir haben schon die ersten Ereignisse. Und man kann das wirklich sich wie ein Foto vorstellen.
Man sieht die Flugbahn von dem Teilchen. Wir sehen, was jeder Teilchendetektor dazu sagt.
Das sind ganz saubere Ereignisse und das ist bei Energien, die sind also mehr
als ein Faktor zwei höher als das, was man vorher konnte.
Und diese Positronen sind sehr empfindliche Sonden für die Natur der dunklen
Materie und deshalb sind wir daran so interessiert.
Das ist ein Beispiel, woran wir sehen, dass die wissenschaftlichen Ergebnisse sehr gut sein werden.
Ob sie sensationell sein werden, das liegt nicht in unserer Hand.
Das heißt, es zeichnet sich auch schon ab, dass jetzt so die Entscheidung für
das Maximum bei zwei Teraelektronenvolt jetzt auch nicht die schlechteste Idee war.
Ich meine, eigentlich ist es keine Entscheidung. Wenn Sie uns gefragt hätten,
was wollt ihr, hätten wir gesagt, 10 Teraelektronenvolt.
Hat aber keiner.
Sondern das, was man technisch kann.
Auch mit dieser Limitierung scheint es schon gut zu funktionieren.
Es funktioniert hervorragend mit der Limitierung. Ob die spannenden physikalischen
Effekte in dem Energiebereich liegen.
Ist offen.
Im Moment müssen wir sagen, dieser
Energiebereich ist nicht vernünftig erforscht. Wir werden das machen.
Ja, nochmal eine Frage zu dem Wir-Kontext. Also eben hörte ich so,
dass wir alle beteiligten Wissenschaftler heraus,
nochmal konkret jetzt hier an den, an der Uni beteiligten Menschen,
sind das dann vor allem auch viele Studenten?
Also ist das quasi dann hier auch Teil der, schon mit der Ausbildung wiederum,
sich aktiv an diesem Gerät mit zu engagieren?
Ja, also wir haben wissenschaftliches Stammpersonal, was die Universität sozusagen hat.
Da haben wir dazu Wissenschaftler, die also vom DLR finanziert werden,
die an dem Projekt mitarbeiten.
Und dann haben wir natürlich eine große Anzahl von Doktoranden,
von Studenten, die ihre Abschlussarbeiten an diesem Projekt machen.
Und das heißt, ja, das macht eigentlich die Attraktivität von solch einem Standort aus.
Also wie viele Möglichkeiten weltweit haben Sie, an solchen Projekten mitzuarbeiten?
Da gibt es relativ wenige.
Deutschland ist also als Industrienation führend genug, wohlhabend genug,
um sich solche Projekte der Grundlagenforschung zu leisten. Und das heißt,
wir können hier an der Grenze dessen, was technisch möglich ist, ausbilden.
Und das ist eine ganz wichtige Funktion.
Das, was mich so ein bisschen traurig macht in dem Zusammenhang,
ist, dass wir so gut ausbilden, dass die Leute teilweise noch in die Industrie
gehen, bevor sie ihre Ausbildung abgeschlossen haben.
Ja, teilweise sind die, also die gehen im Moment weg wie warme Semmel,
ja, die sind weg, bevor sie ihre Abschlussarbeiten fertig haben,
weil die Angebote so gut sind.
Das ist gut aus Sicht des Abnehmers, weil es zeigt,
wir bilden auf dem richtigen Niveau aus, die Leute werden nachgefragt,
aber aus Sicht des Forschers wäre es halt teilweise schön, wenn diese Abschlussarbeiten
abgeschlossen werden könnten.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen schwierig im Moment gegenwärtig. Also dieses Modell
funktioniert hervorragend.
Das muss auch so funktionieren. Wir können nur für etwa 10 Prozent der Leute
eine Karrieremöglichkeit in der Forschung anbieten.
90 Prozent gehen in andere Bereiche.
Und das heißt, diese Ausbildung ist auch in der Physik so universell.
Das eigentliche Ziel ist, ich sage den Studenten immer, euch beizubringen, richtig zu denken.
Also gründlich zu denken, komplexe Probleme zu lösen. Das ist das, was Physiker können.
Die können nicht so viel auswendig wie die Mediziner. Also wenn ich am OP-Tisch
stehe, kann ich mir nicht überlegen, ich muss mal in die Bibliothek gehen und
irgendwas nachschlagen.
Das kann ich nicht machen. Aber als Physiker, die intellektuelle Herausforderung
ist die Komplexität. Bin ich in der Lage, intellektuell das überhaupt zu verstehen?
Nicht, kann ich es mir merken. Kann ich es verstehen?
Und die Anforderungen auch in der Industrie sind immer komplexere Zusammenhänge,
die durchdrungen werden müssen.
Und da sind Physiker extrem hilfreich. Also die Arbeitsmöglichkeiten sind breit
gestreut und nicht irgendwie auf einen Zweig gestreckt.
Und so ganz verloren für die Grundlagenforschung sind sie dann in der Industrie
aber auch nicht oder wie ist das Verhältnis zu sehen?
Häufig sind sie in Forschungsbereichen tätig. Jetzt muss man sich immer wieder
fragen, Grundlagenforschung und Grundlagenforschung.
Die Industrie versteht unter Grundlagenforschung naturgemäß was anderes als
die Universitäten, weil die
Grundlagenforschung in der Industrie soll ja immer eine Anwendung haben.
Ja, das ist die Grundlage für die nächste Anwendung, also für das nächste Produkt.
Die müssen ja Geld verdienen. Ich finde das gar nicht schlecht.
Das heißt, es ist eine staatliche Aufgabe, eigentlich die Grundlagen für die
nächste Generation von Grundlagenforschung in die Industrie zu legen.
Das machen wir an der Universität über solche Sachen wie AMS.
Aber das liefert dann das Ausbildungsniveau, dass die mit dem aktuellen Kenntnisstand,
also das, was Forschung heute kann, in die Industrie reingehen.
Und damit also diesen Wissenstransfer eigentlich leisten von dem,
was auf Universitätsniveau vielleicht funktioniert mit staatlicher Unterstützung,
zu was, was ich also kommerziell dann einsetzen kann.
Sind denn die Universitäten in Deutschland generell gut genug aufgestellt,
um an diesen Grundlagenforschungen auch teilzunehmen, auch vielleicht jenseits der Physik?
Ja. Also wir, wenn man das im internationalen Vergleich sieht,
wir können mit allen Universitäten mithalten, wenn wir das wollen.
Und für mich ist es mehr eine Frage, wo setzt man Prioritäten,
in welchen Bereichen will man das?
Aber wenn wir das wollen, also wir müssen uns nicht hinter ETH Zürich oder MIT
oder Ähnlichem verstecken.
Wenn ich mir angucke, was die anderen Gruppen leisten, was wir leisten können,
wir sind wettbewerbsfähig in jeder Beziehung.
Wie ist denn das jetzt, jetzt ist das AMS da und wenn ich das richtig verstehe,
ist diese ganze Astro-Teilchen-Physik eigentlich ein relativ neues Gebiet noch?
Was muss denn jetzt als nächster Schritt kommen? Worüber wird denn jetzt nachgedacht? Was steht an?
Das Ding ist ja jetzt oben und liefert seine Daten, da kann man jetzt nicht
mehr viel dran drehen. Also man kann natürlich noch dran drehen,
man kann an der Software drehen, etc.
Und man muss vielleicht überhaupt erstmal neue wissenschaftliche Modelle auch
aufbringen, um mit dem Datenstrom auch was anfangen zu können.
Ja, eigentlich heißt auch in der Physik, Sobald das eine Experiment fertig ist,
eigentlich schon vorher, muss man sich darüber Gedanken machen,
was macht man als nächstes?
Wie geht es weiter? Also Aufgabe der Universitäten ist ja, dieses Forschungsfeld
weiterzuentwickeln, also nicht einen gewissen Zustand einzufrieren und dann
100 Jahre das Gleiche zu machen. Also wie entwickeln wir solch ein Gebiet weiter?
Was ich sehr instruktiv finde, ist sich das Hubble Space Teleskop anzugucken
als ein hervorragendes wissenschaftliches Instrument.
Das ist 1989, glaube ich, gestartet worden. geworden.
Es ist jetzt mehr als 20 Jahre in Betrieb. Wenn Sie sich die ersten Bilder von
Hubble angucken und das, was wir heute von Hubble sehen, dann sehen Sie einen
enormen Fortschritt, also in der Technologie dieses Instrumentes.
Das hat was damit zu tun, dass es am Anfang nicht richtig justiert war, das weiß ich alles.
Es musste repariert werden.
Es waren in Größenordnung 6 Missionen notwendig, um dieses Instrument über 20
Jahre am Leben zu halten und auf dem neuesten technischen Stand zu halten.
Das heißt für AMS, wenn wir in der Lage sind, qualitativ ähnlich hochwertige
wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse zu produzieren wie Hubble, was wir zeigen müssen erst,
dann stellt sich die Frage, ob wir diese 20 Jahre auf der Raumstation einfach
sitzen und warten müssen.
Oder ob wir um AMS herum, AMS als Kern, weitere Instrumente drumherum bauen,
die daraus also ein wesentlich leistungsfähigeres Gesamtinstrument machen.
Und das sind Überlegungen, mit denen wir jetzt angefangen haben.
Das lohnt sich aber erst, das ernsthaft zu diskutieren, wenn wir also,
würde ich jetzt mal sagen, im Laufe von 2013 ernsthafte wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse
vorlegen. Und man dann beurteilen kann, inwieweit das sinnvoll ist,
AMS weiter auszubauen oder umzubauen.
Das wäre also eine Möglichkeit, wie sich das weiterentwickeln kann.
Die andere Möglichkeit, die im Raum steht, ist, AMS ist ein ziemliches Universalinstrument
mit seinen ganzen Komponenten, die es da drin hat.
Wenn wir jetzt bestimmte Effekte sehen, kann man sich sehr gut vorstellen,
dass man also für diese Fragestellung optimiert, ein neues Instrument baut,
was man dann nicht unbedingt mit einem Satelliten fliegen muss,
aber in vielen Fällen kann man das also heute mit Stratosphärenballons machen,
die die NASA in der Antarktis starten kann, gegenwärtig als einzige Agentur,
Raumfahrtagentur in der Antarktis.
Und das hat nichts mit den Ballons zu tun, wie wir sie kennen.
Das sind also Ballone mit einem Volumen von einer Million Kubikmeter,
über 100 Meter Durchmesser hat die Hülle.
Die heben Nutzlasten von drei Tonnen hoch und die erreichen Flugdauern in über
30 Kilometer Höhe von mehr als 40 Tagen.
Denn es gibt also im antarktischen Sommer zirkumpolare Winde,
die das stabil halten. Also einfach gesagt kreist das einfach um den Südpol.
Da wohnt auch keiner. Das heißt, man muss sich also nicht so über die Landeplätze Gedanken machen.
Dann wird das irgendwann zur Landung gebracht, indem man also das Helium ablässt.
Ja.
Und auch damit kann man über 99% der Erdatmosphäre hinter sich lassen.
Sodass wir also überlegen müssen, für die nächsten 10, 15 Jahre,
wie sieht das Programm aus? Weltweit muss das überlegt werden.
Werden das Ballonexperimente sein? Wird das ein Ausbau von Von AMS werden das
neue Satellitenexperimente sein.
Und das wird damit zusammenhängen, was wir an wissenschaftlichen Ergebnissen von AMS bekommen.
Also das wird eine Diskussion in den nächsten drei, vier Jahren sein,
dass wir uns also ein entsprechendes Programm überlegen müssen,
wie wir das bei vernünftiger Nutzung der vorhandenen Ressourcen realisieren können.
Ja, man kann ja jetzt davon ausgehen, dass es noch ziemlich lange in Betrieb ist.
Das schreit ja jetzt nicht unbedingt sofort nach einem Ersatzgerät,
was auch unabhängig von der ISS fliegt.
Die ISS hat es ja schon gezeigt, ist eigentlich ein ganz guter Gastgeber mit
der ganzen Stromversorgung etc.
Pp. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Wettkampf im Gange,
um die letzten Mysterien oder zumindest die nächsten anstehenden Mysterien der
Physik da zu entschlüsseln.
Ist denn da, rund um das LHC-Experiment gibt es ja eigentlich so einen generellen
Optimismus, der wahrnehmbar ist, dass man da auch in absehbarer Zeit zu neuen Erkenntnissen kommt,
zumindest durch das Ausscheiden können anderer Varianten.
Wie sehr, was ist Ihre Erwartung, wie sich dieses Feld, was jetzt in den letzten
zehn Jahren schon so durchschüttelt worden ist, durch neue Erkenntnisse in den
nächsten Jahren entwickeln wird?
War es das jetzt erstmal wieder oder geht es jetzt erst richtig los?
Ja, Prognosen sind schwierig, besonders wenn sie die Zukunft betreffen.
Man muss auch immer zwischen Wunsch und Wirklichkeit unterscheiden.
Natürlich ist der Wunsch von allen Beteiligten, dass das passiert,
bevor sie aus dem aktiven Dienst irgendwie ausscheiden.
Es ist wirklich eine eine extrem schwierige frage ich möchte auf zwei aspekte
in dem zusammenhang gehen dass die eine frage die mich umtreibt ist,
Wenn wir nur AMS haben in dieser Form auf der Raumstation und das findet irgendwas
Tolles, wie verifizieren wir das?
Ich habe versucht, in dem Gespräch klarzumachen, dass das ein sehr komplexes Instrument ist.
Also wie schließen wir aus, dass das, was wir beobachten, ein Artefakt aus der
Konstruktion dieses Experiments ist?
Was wir in der Vergangenheit deshalb immer gemacht haben, wenn Sie sich die
Beschleunigerexperimente angucken, wir haben immer mehrere gemacht.
Also an dem LHC gibt es deshalb zwei Instrumente, die das machen,
die das völlig unabhängig voneinander machen.
Bei AMS versuchen wir das jetzt so ein bisschen, indem wir sagen,
wir machen zwei Analysegruppen auf, die völlig unabhängig voneinander arbeiten
und am Ende erst ihre Ergebnisse vergleichen.
Unterschiedliche Instrumente oder nur unterschiedliche Auswertungswege?
Unterschiedliche Auswertungswege. Unterschiedliche Instrumente können wir nicht.
Es gibt nur ein AMS. Ja, okay.
Von daher ist es schon eine relevante Frage, bin ich in der Lage mit vielleicht
weniger aufwendigen Experimenten, aber verschiedene Details dann nachzumessen,
um sicher zu sein, dass das kein Problem von dem Instrument ist.
Also mit der Frage werden wir uns beschäftigen müssen.
Die zweite Frage ist, was wird in den nächsten zehn Jahren passieren?
Wenn man sich die Sensitivität der jetzigen Generationen von Messinstrumenten
anguckt, dann müssten wir eigentlich in den nächsten zehn Jahren eine Antwort
auf die Natur der dunklen Materie finden oder es gibt sie nicht.
Und wenn es sie nicht gibt, dann gibt es irgendwas anderes, was wir nicht verstanden
haben. Da ist irgendwas grundlegend faul dann.
Jetzt kann man sagen, ihr habt den ganzen Aufwand betrieben und dann habt ihr
nur verstanden, dass es nicht das ist, was ihr dachtet, was es ist.
Was ist denn der Fortschritt? Der Fortschritt war zu verstehen,
dass es keinen Äther gibt und dass sich elektromagnetische Wellen im Vakuum
ausbreiten und dass die Lichtgeschwindigkeit konstant ist und das ist die Grundlage
für das GPS, was wir heute benutzen,
Die Wissenschaft ist nicht immer eine gerade Linie Sie können nicht sagen,
wie geht das also über die nächsten 50 Jahre etwa weiter Wir werden garantiert Umwege machen,
um zu den Ergebnissen zu kommen Das andere ist immer die Frage,
welchen Anspruch kann man haben dass das in nächster Zeit passiert.
Wenn Sie sich mal angucken zwischen Newton und Einstein, das waren mehrere hundert Jahre.
Und die Leute dazwischen waren auch nicht dumm und haben auch nicht geschlafen.
Aber es kann sein, dass es einfach ein kultureller Schritt ist,
den Sie erst zurücklegen müssen, bevor Sie in der Lage sind,
diese Erkenntnisse zu gewinnen.
Also Newton hätte, egal wie genial er ist, ohne die Vorarbeiten,
die also zwischen Newton und Einstein passiert sind, Also Newton hätte nicht
die Relativitätstheorie finden können.
Die Mathematik war überhaupt nicht so weit. Die Menschen waren überhaupt nicht in der Lage dazu.
Ob wir heute qualifiziert sind, um den nächsten Schritt auf dieser Erkenntnistreppe
zurückzulegen oder nicht, ist schwer zu sagen, bevor wir das nicht gemacht haben.
Ja, im Moment versuchen wir es an verschiedenen Stellen und wir finden an verschiedenen
Stellen, es geht nicht so schnell weiter, wie wir das gerne hätten.
Ja, also beim LAC haben wir auch erwartet, dass wir im ersten halben Jahr endlich
die neue Physik sehen und wissen, wie es weitergeht. Es scheint wesentlich schwieriger zu sein.
Was nicht heißt, dass man es aufgeben sollte, sondern nur, dass es nicht klar
ist, wie wir zu diesen Erkenntnissen kommen, von denen ich fest davon überzeugt
bin, dass sie eigentlich da sind, dass sie uns im Moment noch nicht zugänglich sind.
Ja, ich fasse zusammen. Es bleibt spannend in der Astroteilchenphysik für das
AMS-Experiment und vor allem natürlich auch in der Grundlagenforschung der Physik im Allgemeinen.
Ich denke, jetzt können wir das hier an der Stelle auch erst mal vorerst abschließen.
Wir bleiben gespannt, inwiefern sich da hier neue Erkenntnisse bieten.
Und ja, mal gucken. Vielleicht können wir ja hier im Rahmen der Raumzeitserie
dann auch schon noch die nächsten Schritte mitnehmen.
Aber jetzt erst mal vielen Dank, Stefan Scheel, für die Ausführungen hier zum
AMS und Bedeutung auch der Astro-Teilchenphysik und den damit verbundenen Experimenten.
Und auch vielen Dank für das Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit. Das war die 38.
Ausgabe und in zwei Wochen gibt es uns wieder. Ich sage Tschüss und bis bald.